peu
[Musique]
tous ont de quoi tu me parles tu rigoles
ou quoi la radio à la télé les journaux
tout le monde enfin à le truc mais oui
ce matin chez lui auprès si ma tante ou
alors ça veut dire que tout le monde
amis lucion du soir bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde en parle vous
connaissez le principe tout le monde en
parle
alors tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez laurent ruquier le récit
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir lent en sortir et comment ça va
très bien tout en forme
oui vous faites après l'émission laurent
qu'est ce que je fais après l'émission
on est samedi soir sortait peut-être
peut-être ce n'est pas la peine
[Musique]
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande de vous arrêter
mise à part laurent ruquier nous
recevrons ce soir samy naceri oui
et eric raoult et julie depardieu
alexandre jardin
et deux minutes 15 secondes ça vous gêne
pas parce que je sais que vous l'avez
traité de passoires thermiques à sa
grande
oui oh oui à l'époque où le psg il est
très malin et dernier match et même pas
c'est lui qui était vraiment dans les
buts à ce qui s'était fait traiter de
passoire bien alors laurent vous publiez
un livre qui s'appelle je ne vais pas me
gêner
ben voilà le livre de laurent ruquier
alors mes enfants c'est chez plon
alors il ya plein de diaby ya plein de
trucs c'est très rigolo il ya moi j'ai
noté un peu les trucs qui me faisait
marrer dans me sens par exemple vous dit
qu'il a mis quatre ans pour pourra
rapporter les propos antisémites de
françois mitterrand est vite que lui il
aurait été dénonciateur mais après la
guerre il a évidemment faut se rappeler
évidemment de cette époque où d'ormesson
a dit a raconté avoir déjeuné avec
mitterrand et que mitterrand il ya verra
quoi raconter des trucs odieux quoi
finalement
mais ça fait pas beaucoup rire les
jeunes qui sont ici parce que d'ormesson
ils savent pas qui c'est il croit qu'il
est mort en même temps que mitterrand
alors céline dion on vous dit elle est
rentrée dans le dictionnaire mais là
c'est lui qui sait d'ormesson
voilà ça tu vois thierry tu prends les
mauvais exemples
céline dion vous connaissez à la alors
on dit dans son bouquin qui allait
rentrer dans le dictionnaire mais
clinverse ça aurait été difficile et
chez total quand on a dix points total
un droit à quoi maintenant ah bah ça
dépend
on va avoir le droit à une pipe de
christine deviers joncour partie bien
alors vous savez il ya une tradition
dans cette émission c'est de regarder
chaque semaine les meilleurs moments de
la semaine précédente parce que encore
des gens qui me regardent pas tout le
monde en parle moi je regarde bah voila
je sais mais quand je regarde voilà donc
on va regarder le best-of de la semaine
dernière ça s'appelle tout le monde en a
parlé
magnéto serge dubeau autobiographique ah
non c'est une mauvaise qu'à 3 marié
plein d'enfants par assistante mais ça
c'est baronne et je t'emmerde saumurage
pas des baronnes je vois sa première
histoire de barron's aïssa vous en
remettez pas mais pourquoi mais moi j'ai
jamais vu au midi libre que c'est un
plouc non syndical voyait mitterrand
mais qu'en fait ils croyaient vachement
à l'astrologie qui voulait faire une
chaîne une chaire parts dans deux
d'astrologie la sorbonne nous dit que
c'est du pipeau tout cela oui
il met son temps et il a tapé françoise
de panafieu est-ce que vous avez déjà
couché pour du boulot on va c'est à dire
que là comme on ne prête qu'aux riches
mille fois c'est à dire que je passe ma
vie je me demande d'ailleurs comment je
suis encore assiste cela énoncée depuis
que j'ai dit à une émission télé que
j'étais copain yves bertrand delanoë que
vous n'êtes pas gentil avec moi
sur les joues
mais ça m
un pasa je suis de gauche je ne voterai
jamais à drap ou dit la voiture c'était
une sa bulle son havre de paix et alors
ça sert à quoi il écoute est vraiment
pink floyd dans la voiture oui les
couteaux pink floyd ça c'est qu'il a ses
trucs qui m'a le plus étonné depuis dix
ans
mitterrand gecko de pink floyd bill
feuilles supertramp les bee gees
ils chantaient des chants vous manger de
la nourriture végétale fabuleux ça c'est
très joli et c'est très bon vous êtes
pourrite ofaj en fait oui j'achète dvd
des fruits je les oublie et six semaines
plus tard il commence à devenir bon et
est-ce qu'on peut éventuellement
t'envoyer des aliments qui sont avec
danielle mitterrand un couple qui était
bâtie sur le respect mutuel c'est ce que
vous dites et puis avec anne pingeot une
véritable passion amoureuse quoi vous le
saviez vous vous étiez au courant parce
que j'ai tous les journalistes étaient
au courant apparemment ils n'ont jamais
dit aux gens qui lisent les journaux
mais je crois que c'est l'honneur des
français et de savoir faire ça on a
beaucoup dépensé pour planquer nos
maîtresses on est bien trop vite
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est si vous étiez jean tiberi ou
feriez quoi
françoise je briserai de briser les
genoux de françoise shanxi
si vous étiez françoise de panafieu ou
feriez quoi montrer les fouilles des
jeux
voilà c'était tout le monde en a parlé
le best-of de la semaine dernière alors
laurent ruquier on va continuer avec
vous sur votre wii précision
continuez sur votre bouquin donc je ne
vais pas me gêner
alors si vous de huitième livre 1 quand
même avec déjà 3 9e ont à dire nous dit
un don d alors c'est un recueil de
textes que vous faites la radio ou sur
scène sur l'année écoulée
maintenant ces rituels sûr que tous les
ans il y aura le ruquier à la même
époque
si je continue à bosser au quotidien ça
continue à écrire un livre par an
exactement
alors y'a un truc est très drôle c'est
la pilule du lendemain dans les écoles a
laissé sans voix
c'est une des mesures que ségolène royal
a prise avant de partir avant l'aller
plus ministre à l'enseignement mais
avant de partir elle a institué la
pilule du lendemain dans l'elysée comme
moi je suis plutôt pour à parce que
d'abord se retrouver enceinte à 14 ans
adopte très rigolo mais en revanche ça
change les conversations des jeunes
l'autre jour j'ai entendu un gamin dire
à une gamine qui donc est ce qu on fait
l'amour ce soir et lui a répondu non non
mais j'ai pas école de magie et vient
constant merdes en a
[Applaudissements]
et regardez le le plus chiant ce sont
les catholiques intégristes qui disent
que la pilule du lendemain c'est déjà un
avortement ça franchement c'est
n'importe quoi est ce qu'un coup de pied
aux couilles c'est le début d'un ivg
c'est à se demander alors le t-shirt i
dosing birkin le 1er avril ah bah oui
elle porte un t-shirt le 1er avril avec
marquez poitrine d'un côté et dos de
l'autre pour qu'on accroche bien le
poisson alors oui vous écrivez aussi que
c'est alors que julien lepers lui j'ai
voulu accrocher un poisson là le 1er
avril dernier j'ai pas pu le faire parce
qu'il a fait encore celui de l'année
dernière
vous dites que 50 à 80 % des athlètes se
dope et des autres y sont ils sont
français ils sont français
voilà dans le bouquin est plein de
desailly de ce petit plomb inquiet je ne
vais pas me gêner voilà alors vous
faites toujours des gars là un rêve bien
sûr vous êtes au théâtre de paris du 2
au 14 mars à 15 heures à paris pour
terminer la tournée puisque ça fait
quand même presque sept ans que je
tourne je passais par paris au théâtre
grévin occasion de paris année dernière
et là on fait 15 jours 15 derniers jours
à paris du 2 au 14 mai après vous
arrêter la scène pendant un ou deux ans
jusqu'aux présidentielles
exactement je reviendrai en même temps
que tous les candidats des déchets d'y
aller au théâtre de paris du 2 au 14 mai
manitou moser aller pour terminer cette
revue des ministres il nous reste les
communistes évidemment important avec
monsieur des sceaux il poserait pas de
faire il ya plusieurs ministres disent
qu'ils sont toujours là ils composent la
majorité la majorité planque et ça c'est
important sur quelqu'un qui tient c'est
grâce à lui d'ailleurs qui sont toujours
au gouvernement c'est monsieur robert
faute coché oui parce que us est un
diminutif
et ils ont pris uniquement pour le
slogan supérieur entre la super marchait
mais la vente continue pendant les
travaux au nom mais je le trouve sympa
tosh mois robert non il hérite par
rapport à ce qu'ils avaient il ya des
agents au pc je rigole on peut pas
imaginer un seul instant fait robert hue
était il ya quelques années un agent du
kgb franchement un agent de câbles et
jardins à la limite mais chaque année
quand je le vois sur la pelouse de la
courneuve
pourvu qu'on nous ne voulons pas pendant
la limite nous terminerons par la
ministre écolo du gouvernement
remarqué pour une écolo c'est normal
qu'elles soient sans plomb mais quand
même oh la pauvre domino non attention
jeu je trouve qu'on a un peu chargées
sur cette histoire de marée noire entre
nous la l'autre le philippe de villiers
petites hontes depuis du fuel on
l'appelle mal alors il aurait pu la
mazout et l'avoine et il l'aurait fait
un mais à quoi ça servait qu'elle
revienne plus tôt que prévu sur le
franchement art et servez à quoi sur les
plages 2010 à un mixeur et elisabeth
guigou et chirac
j'aurais compris la garde des sceaux est
celui qui se ramasse des peines aurait
été parfait mais vous allez franchement
puis alors il est allé plus croyez moi y
aurait plus de dominique voynet au
gouvernement et moins de philippe de
villiers dans la politique qui se
passerait peut-être pas ce genre de
catastrophe ça crée un malaise
non ok ça s'appelle gentil pour la
dernière fois
dépêchez vous donc parce qu'après
pendant deux ans il ya plus de laurent
ruquier sur scène voilà vous êtes
content là qu'ils doivent de votre votre
carrière là c'est pas mal non mais rien
c'est un grand mot et tout se passe bien
j'ai pas me plaindre depuis dix ans que
je suis à paris je fais ce métier
effectivement je n'ai pas à me plaindre
depuis vous êtes partis du havre du
havre ouais vous étiez cinq enfants et
s'est assis à table c'est autour de la
table que les vannes se balance et c'est
là que vous avez choper cette culture et
que votre père ouais c'est vrai ça mon
père lui-même raconté pas mal de 2,2
blague pas des blagues en fait il va
n'est pas l'ailé les enfants les mêmes
ma mère sa femme bloquée entre nous donc
on a pris la relève et ont commencé à
raconter des conneries et bien sûr les
autres autour des tables c'est vrai
quand vous étiez petit dont faisait
pitié le luron chaban guy béart
ouais je faisais tout les imitations que
le luron faisait c'était l'époque du
général de lur ans j'étais en cm2
j'imitais un imitateur
comme beaucoup d autres imitateurs ont
fait après et votre la révélation pour
vous je savais pas je l'aï appris en
lisant votre bouquin c'est dans la
préface la révélation pour vous ça a été
un jour dans un déménagement vous
quittez le votre famille quitte le hlm
de votre enfance pour une une maison
dans la haute ville
et dans la cave vous trouvez un bouquin
de pierre doris de 14 ans alors là leur
demandez pas qui est pierre de risques
parce que la gendarmerie sont vous
connaissez pas anodin car d'origine
alors on peut rappeler qu'ils savent
bien volontiers moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on dise un mot parce que c'est le
premier comics méchant quoi voilà
exactement c'est le premier à voir
pratiquer l'humour méchant l'humour noir
dans les cabarets et ça a été un des
premiers sur qui à qui j'ai piqué des
histoires je veux dire à l'époque parce
que moi j'écrivais pas moi j'étais gamin
et vous lisiez les histoires dans un
bouquin qui s'appelait l'histoire
méchant voilà publié chez ceux-là et à
l'école entre eux entre les cours je
raconter aux copains des histoires mais
j'attribuais ces histoires là ma propre
famille est-ce que doris évidemment
raconter ça sur sa propre famille à lui
or c'était du genre
dis donc qu'est ce que tu aimes bien et
elle est ce que tu aimes bien ta mère
oui bertrand ans l'a dit donc laurent
enlève le ans lève le doigt de l'oeil de
ta petite soeur sinon je ferme le
cercueil en souviens c'est été annoncée
des choses attendez pierre doris c'était
vraiment mais ça que je suis méchant
depuis belle lurette pas d'y aller elle
est montée sur ressorts il dit
je sais pas laquelle ce thème et estimé
que ses fils et trois baffes à la mort
si je suis méchant depuis divisée mais
c'est rien mais sans pression
mais non égalée embrasser
[Applaudissements]
et elle est tellement habitué à regarder
la gaffe à la pas l'habitude a fallu
dire que c'est pour déconner ça courir
pierre doris était quelqu'un c'était
quelqu'un qui était très en avance une
espèce de près coluche de près des
proches à l'enterrement de tino rossi ou
je ne sais pas il réinvente
l'enterrement de tino rossi alors on met
tino rossi dans le trou et puis les gens
applaudissent alors on a été obligé de
le monter de remonter dix fois pour
faire les rappels pas des choses
terribles garde aux russes mais je pense
que le livre et je pense que le livre
doit se trouver pour les gens que ça
intéresse ça les pilotes de 61 qui est
publié chez solar ça s'appelle histoire
méchante voilà alors votre vie
quotidienne c'est pas le regrette parce
que vous vous lever à 4 heures 45
ouais 4h45 et j'arrive à la station à
europe 1 vers 5h25 5h30 et quand vous
vous couchez à 4h30 comment vous faites
alors quand je me 4h30 du matin oui je
me couche jamais à 4h30 du matin quand
je me lève à 16h45 bien alors on va vous
voulez m'emmener quelque part
non
génial je vous demande de vous arrêter
voilà non c'est sympa c'est que ça vous
rappelle vos débuts il a été dj j'étais
disquaires en disait à l'époque chez les
disquaires au whisky à gogo à
juan-les-pins retali ensemble à la
dernière tournée mais on a versé une
larme mais on a fait un pèlerinage
jusqu'à vous est ce que vous savez vous
ne pas mâcher au coude et dj elle est
morte sous un tunnel
oui elle en méchant bida c'est thierry
ardisson est capable d'expliquer on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle ça c'est
formidable c'est énorme
ans
bon bah il n'a pas bougé il discipline
et c'est laurent ruquier plaisir il vous
a bien dressés marc olivier fogiel
jospin qui m'a dit il faut prôner
l'immobilisme de ce côté là il est fort
dites moi
bon on va faire une interview à l'envers
donc je vous donne les réponses et vous
me donnez les questions c'est compliqué
ça non si vous allez voir si je vous dis
par exemple laurence boccolini alors
j'explique à mes amis téléspectateurs
c'est la jeune femme qui a remplacé sa
mère-grand mouvement fatah essayé de
remplacer laurent ruquier sur sur
français un père laurence boccolini faut
que je trouve la question trouvez la
question qui veut qui devait amener à
cette réponse que la fille qui n'aurait
pas dû appeler son émission rien à voir
quand elle a voulu remplacer la nuit
alors laurence boccolini a été remplacée
récemment par stéphane bern ce qui
prouve bien que laurent ruquier est
irremplaçable puisque linda hardy n'est
pas arrivé non plus alors si je vous dis
stéphane bern
quelle est la question fait les
questions et les réponses à ce que moi
je fais la réponse je vous dit stéphane
bern quelle est la question quel est le
type qui montre ses dents pour montrer
qu'il a autant de couronnes que de celle
du type vous aviez dit en parlant de
vous aviez dit en parlant de stéphane
bern s'est appelée rien à cirer
maintenant ça s'appelle tout acier c'est
très bien aussi si je vous dis laurent
gerra laurent gerra alors ben c'est la
question la semu alors quel est le type
à qui vous avez succédé sur europe 1 et
que vous avez aidé je crois à faire
démarrer sur france inter guillaume
durand
quel est le type qui fait beaucoup de
succès à fixer avec ses bouquins mais
pas beaucoup avec ses émissions de télé
bruno gaccio alors bas à qui avez-vous
succédé sur canal+ auprès de marque audi
vous en sortez bien quand vous êtes dans
la succession là et c'est vous qui me
l'annoncer pas vous n'êtes pas obligé de
poser tous et dans la succession se dire
marc olivier fogiel votre grand ami elle
est bien c'est celui qui vous a remplacé
dans mon coeur je le comprends comme ça
samy naceri samina s'il calait l'invité
qui va vous succéder
[Musique]
sexy balle samy naceri comment ça va
super bien
je l'appelle le beurre aux yeux bleus
mais tu aimes pas vous aimez pas qu'on
vous appelle beurre préféré maghrébins
je crois wemmel birth et sur les
tartines le matin et il est je le beurre
aux yeux bleus bon alors ça roule à
ouais c'est le cas de le dire ça roule
donc on va parler de retraite si le taxi
2 qui est bien parti pour faire 10
millions d'entrées on est à 4 millions
ça sera plus que 10 alors on est à 4
millions on a fait la moitié un peu plus
de la moitié de la vie de taxi 1 sur 10
je sais pas un nom d'exploitation il
était assez mignon et on est à 4
millions en une semaine
c'est incroyable mais j'ai vu là j'ai
pas encore vu le 2 mai je vis et deviens
était bien en arrière mais c'était bien
donc vous avez battu les visiteurs vous
avez battu et star wars et je veux
danger pokémon il a quoi de plus que le
premier le deuxième rang il va plus vite
ah ça va encore plus vite huawei il va
plus vite
besson a fait en sorte d'étau fait tous
les personnages à vous avez moins
conduit à cotisation suive un nom ouais
on ne pouvait pas je n'ai pas pu me
faire plaisir comme je me suis fait
plaisir sur le ventre ouais ce que s'il
nous est arrivé un malheur la faute il
aurait été dommage qu'on ait deux voilà
c'est fini
taxi 3 c'est déjà écrit dans la tête de
l'ue coin ouais ouais
pressez écrire c'est tranquille c'est un
bon boulot maintenant je crois que ça
roule quoi faut pas tomber dans le
ridicule et puis jacques besson c'est un
mec l'intelligence vivre l attaque si
les extraterrestres
non mais bon les gendarmes y en a bien
eu 4 je veux dire je crois qu'on peut se
permettre d'aller jusqu'au 4 comme
l'armé fatale et pourquoi 5e 6 leucate
le public est au rendez vous on s'en
remettra de faire un cinquième alors
jusqu'à jusqu'à daniel si vous aviez
tout le temps des rôles de maghrébins
comme vous dites c'est à dire que
finalement c'est la première fois même
en france je crois que c'est la première
fois que il ya un acteur qui s'appelle
daniel et qui joue pas parce que dans
rail vous et votre banc le film de
thomas gilou en 94 vous vous jouiez des
gens de la banlieue est là pour la
premier c'est la première fois que ouais
je crois qu'il y en a quand même un
petit peu il ya hier jeudi il ya sami
bouadjila il ya saïd taghmaoui qui a
réussi à peu à travailler aux états unis
je crois qu'on est
et puis c'est pas une mode je crois
qu'on est on est on est quatre cinq six
la dent dans le milieu du cinéma ou
où les gens nous commence à nous donner
je dis depuis un bon bout à bien avant
demain mais nous on commence aussi à se
faire notre petite place si on nous
donne des rôles comme ça de français ou
alors si c'est des rôles de deux
maghrébins des jolis rôles quoi que je
dise et roschdy zem approche ils pensent
que c'est salman rushdie on sait jamais
avant il y avait au marché arif
muluzi en france sharif et mouloudji
on a parlé excusez moi mais ce soir on a
quand même parlé de sa génération
d'ormesson pierre doris évolutif qui
jouait dans fiac run away
bon alors le deuxième place et le
premier film taxi bon c'est un triomphe
absolu
le deuxième film c'est un film qui sort
le 12 avril est un film d'alexandre
arcady qui s'appelle là bas mon pays
tirée du roman de rené donald qui est un
bouquin excellent voilà que zoom zoom
bon garçon je montre à la caméra zoome
s'était dit voilà alors avec antoine de
caunes mathilda may qui d'autre noah
quadra ouais alors l'histoire c'est
l'histoire de d'antoine de caunes au
départ qui est une star de la télé qui
présente le journal télévisé un jour et
rencontre un vieil algérien devant la
chaîne de télé web os et se souvienne
j'ai rien lui montre une cassette où il
ya une jeune fille qui enlève son voile
devant la caméra et on lui demande
d'aller la chercher parce que évidemment
les très en danger ça se passe en 94
donc à l'époque avait le génial fils etc
et donc il part en algérie pour faire
sortir pour faire sortir cette fille et
il s'aperçoit que c'est la fille d'une
fille qu'il avait abandonné en 62 et là
on découvre que lui et pieds-noirs en
fait il avait complètement renier tous
sens pas ses pieds noirs et lâche bac
entre un entrelacement entre 62 et 94
alors voilà ben écoutez le plus simple
c'est qu'on regarde un ce qu'on regarde
un extrait magnéto serge
[Musique]
mr et mme pierre jammes les charges et
qu'est ce que tu crois pas possible
et là il à sa fille qu'elle lui
ressemble amina ce présent pisam mon ami
d'enfance mon frère voilà chers qu'à
mieux à l'aja depuis j'avais pas le
choix sa mère est née il dit rugby ça
partout depuis hier sur les marchés à la
gare dans les taxis partout cette fatwa
ans tel que ce soit une fatwa locales
pour faire taire bien en gros tu es
condamné anwar n'aurait pas tenu plus
d'une demi heure dans les rues d'alger
c'est encore plus jolie que ta mère toi
voilà ça s'appelle là bas mon pays c'est
un film d'alexandre arcady qu'antoine de
caunes samy naceri ça sort le 12 avril
voilà ce que je voulais dire c'est que
moi j'ai arcalis et quelqu'un qui m'a
fait rêver qui m'a donné envie de faire
du cinéma et je rêvais de tourner avec
lui et l'a donc j'ai une participation
amicale et j'avais envie de jouer ce
rôle de ce mec qui se bat pour la
liberté en 62 et qui se bat encore
aujourd'hui pour la liberté et mon
personnage est important pour le
dénouement de l'histoire et que c'est
une belle participation amicale quoi
c'est très émouvant - tous les cas ça
m'a beaucoup touché je suis sorti de là
j'étais beau votre père est venu en
france en cas à quelle époque il est
venu bien avant l'indépendance
il est venu bien avant dépendance il
vendait des fleurs dans les halles
il a rencontré ma mère tu es normande
qui est normande qui explique les yeux
bleus à la gare saint lazare et ils sont
plus quittés voilà c'est pas beau ci lui
a demandé de porter les valises et
depuis alors votre père était donc
peintre en bâtiment après oui vous avez
une enfance assez modeste dans un deux
pièces six enfants dans la même chambre
mais c'était bien ouais ouais puis après
mon père ici le taper pour qu'on bouge
un peu quoi donc la peinture il en a
fait un vrai métier quoi un don qu'il
s'est battu pour qu'on bouge de là où
j'en étais et pour nous donner une vraie
éducation qui de quoi aller à l'école
qui et puis j'avais ma mère qui était là
aussi pour veiller à tout ça et mais on
était tous ensemble dans cette chambre
j'en ai mes frères et soeurs mais
c'était bien c'est là où on a commencéà
j'ai commencé et puis mes frères aussi à
nourrir des rêves de cinéma et or
faisait toutes les scènes de des films d
euros des fossiles aux idées vous et des
péplums voilà un y'avait dire qu'il y
avait il y avait un rideau qui séparait
la chambre des enfants de la chambre des
parents est une idée dans la chambre des
enfants évidemment et il faisait des
péplums il jouait recul et cléopâtre on
va vous rappeler des souvenirs
là
[Musique]
samy naceri bon ça me vous pourriez
jouer dans voyez jouer dans un
impeccable
j'aimerais bien vous avez vraiment la
tête à jouer dans ce même le dernier
qu'on avait avant vous c'était cédric
pioline donc avis aux producteurs vous
êtes bon comme la romaine bien qu'alors
tout de suite votre idole ça était gamin
dit si j'arrive à avoir 20% de l'amour
que les français portent à gabat je
serai ravi ça sera vraiment
l'aboutissement dans ma vie ouais c'est
un mec
je veux dire tout ce qu'il a fait tout
ce qu'il a touché il a joué des rôles
complètement différent je veux dire les
misérables le singe en hiver le clan des
siciliens il jouait le parrain il joue
un avocat il joue un flic qui jouait la
commisaire gazole dans la ville jumelle
tout ça ouais c'est le mec et ouais
franchement si si je pourrai wayne ne
serait semaine 10 % 10 % avec ça se
négocie relais pour cent j'en ai redit
pour ça évolue ce que je disais cet
après midi j'aurai voulu arriver dans le
cinéma et avoir ma petite place dans le
cinéma ou au gabon est encore là il ne
serait ce que de me retrouver sur un
plateau avec lui et pouvoir parler un
petit peu avec lui quoi et une scène
alors ça aurait été merveilleux faut se
méfier quand on dit je voudrais 10%
lorsqu'il de gabao parce que il y en a
un qui voudraient 10% de belmondo et
s'appelle michel creton attention alors
vous rêviez vous rêviez à jean gabin
l'école bon ce n'est pas très très très
bien passé vettel en pension êtes fan
plus jeter et un jour annoncée à vos
parents que vous voulez être comédien et
il vous dit laissant sur terre va bosser
au marché que tes frères quoi hélas
malgré tout vous y avez cru envers et
contre tous et je me suis dit j'ai dit
je vous y croyez pas assez un peu
ralenti arrivera pas à mon pote c'est
pas possible pas bon j'y arriverai pas
et je me suis tapé comme un fou jallet
alors j'étais pas préparé j'arrivais
avec deux trois photos complètement nul
décév et mal taper depuis je me suis
fait jeter toutes les portes à se fermer
ben ouais qui sait comment vous êtes qui
savait quoi quoi la laque réécrit
menacée non vous rigolez une ombre au
quesnoy mais j'ai pas le temps là
d'accord et puis je suis tombé sur un
mec bruno de l'est ouais qui m'a été
présenté par ma prof de théâtre et c'est
lui qui m'a mis le pied à l'étrier
killer kid le premier gilles de maistre
vous venez de refaire un film de leurs
actifs de metz dont kerry principal
c'est un garçon fidèles main de celui
qui vous a donné votre première chance
et aujourd'hui vous êtes le star et vous
travailler avec lui ça s'appelle féroce
ouais on se disait rappelle samir il ya
80 et avec moi qui leur kit tu faisais
tu avais une petite figure et a été
coupée au montage
j'en avais parlé à tout le monde savait
raconter à tout le monde tu vas voir
j'ai fait un film on ne sait pas dans le
film
c'est vrai j'étais pas j'étais j'étais
comme un fou j'avais dit à mes parents à
tout le monde vous avez vu vous m'avez
dit non c'est pas possible et tout ma
charge et j'allais faire un film je suis
resté 15 jours sur le film là et venez
venez je suis arrivé j'attendais ma
scène j'attendais ma saine gestion d un
point à un moment donné au fond et puis
pour les blues mais si vous êtes arrivé
une autre fois c'est vrai il faut dire
la vérité quand vous avez connu
besson dont vous jouez dans dans les
rayons avec une cagoule et à la fin du
tournage b110 quand même le pauvre samy
naceri on le voit pas quand même donc ce
serait quand même bien qu'on le bat
l'angleterre ni jour il du coup tu
enlèves ta cagoule comme ça on va devoir
mais c'était une c'était une belle
rencontre à une belle rencontre et et la
gg j'ai senti que
que le mec qu'il s'intéressait à moi
quoique que j'étais là et il parlait
avec les techniciens il me regardait
comme ça et puis dit lui un machin et je
suis arrivé donc dans les moulins de
paris il y avait une scène où jean reno
se déguise en soit et puis il fait
semblant de se sauver il est blessé donc
les autres soit l'aide à sortir et m'a
dit tiens ça me tue l'avenir méritée on
évite acadienne jean reno donc c'est
génial pour moi tu fais une cents avec
jean reno et au montage et de la fumée
partout et on voit rien dire
alors vas voir l'époque des galères de
samy naceri l'époque des répondeurs son
message le soir aidé et des castings
inutile magnéto ok ça me tue peut porter
sa part terre alors sa famille raconte
nous un petit peu qui tu es tu viens ce
que tu fais en ce moment je l'appelle la
série ça les sort à peine du milieu des
sites et bien ils mendient
fontenay-sous-bois montera et autres je
suis passionné de théâtre aussi marché
du théâtre à la formation de rizières
je fais des marchés pour gagner ma vie
j'ai essayé de courir les castings à
droite à gauche pour pour essayer
d'obtenir des petits rôles parce que ça
me plaît voilà pourquoi dira donc
vraiment les histoires de sites et de
tout ça qu'on s'est montré le confiner
dans les cités je connais pas mal de
choses
d'accord
je suis demandé d'être levée je mesure
combien 80,33 d'accord tu vas me montrer
tes profil ok pour notre profil ok très
bien tu meures gains samy naceri est
aujourd'hui triomphe payant dans taxi
pour la deuxième fois
c'est émouvant j'étais bien joufflu et
tout et c'est bruno qui qui fait le
casting et il m'avait dit là je le
saoulais je l'appelais tous les jours et
je dis bon alors quand est-ce qu'on fait
le film bruno delaye
ouais une jatte angevins il me dit
écoute je vais faire le casting à la une
période d'essai de passer son personne
te voyais amène moi une faute au tac tac
tac je me suis faufilé j'ai rien dit à
personne je suis rentré dans le bureau
j'ai sorti une photo et c'est un peu mon
c'est lui qui fait le truc c'est génial
de voir sa [ __ ] c est bien et voilà
image rose et sahel
ça me fait plaisir pour toi ça merci
alors il a un problème quand même c'est
que tout le monde te dis enfin tout le
monde vous disais il faut changer votre
nom parce que saïd ça marchera jamais
naceri ça va encore parce que la série
ça fait à peu corps si tallien enfin bon
ça peut passer mais ça passe pas et et
vos parents vous disais c'est pas une
question de talent parce que bon mais
tant que tu auras un prénom arabe on ne
fera jouer les arabes alors vous avez
choisi sami c'est un surnom maintenant
de ses amis c'est plus que c'est presque
plus qu'un prénom nom ouais mais il ya
peu de gens m'a même ma mère mes frères
aujourd'hui ma mère - parce que je
m'appelle encore saïd mais mes frères
mes amis les copains tout ça ils ont
pris l'habitude de m'appeler ça me met
surtout quoi quand au début les journaux
de merde là ils n'ont pas dévoilé mon
vrai prénom pour pour m'assassiner
il n'y avait pas beaucoup de gens qui
savaient que je m'appelais cei tout le
monde croyait que c'était ça me donc
même mais comment il faisait super gaffe
quand on arrive et puis qu'on était dans
des fêtes un cinéma tout ça qui faisait
les grammy et donc ça a joué le jeu et
tout ça mais c'est vrai que c'était
difficile j'ai même pensé un moment à
m'appeler pierre morel ou ferment
j'ai bien morel et je me suis dit au
jour d'aujourd'hui est ce que j'aurais
fait ce que les la carrière que voilà
qu'arrive enfin les films que j'ai faits
comme raï comme petit ben comme tout ça
quoi
peut-être qu'on ne les aurait pas donné
ouais alors vous allez changer aussi
vous avez vous avez peu fait attention à
votre langage vous dites plus comme ça
je kiffe ou s'est lentement
c'est fini ça qui vous êtes habillé un
peu plus il faut l'avouer
comme annoncé le succès donc retrouvé de
la place au restaurant vous avec votre
mobile chez disney dimanche n'a pas de
soucis vous passez devant tout le monde
voilà quoi il malgré tout malgré tout
quand même des fois vous pétez un peu
les programmes il ya certains soirs
quand même vous j'ai le truc c'est que
c'est sur les deux derniers coups qui a
eu franchement ça valait pas ce à quoi
j'ai tout le monde qui n'a pas bu quatre
verres de whisky en boîte et puis s'est
retrouvé au volant il sentait qu'il
pouvait conduire le pire c'est que j'ai
changer de conducteur s'était pas à moi
la voiture et vous êtes des lancers en
disant si le mec
ouais je vais dire que c'est moi qui
conduisais comme ça mon pote et laura
rien et les matières brunes temps n'ont
du coup ça mais bon j'étais j'ai j'avais
un petit coup moi aussi donc j'étais
encore avec certainement
et si même sûr parce que vous dites
quand même c'est que dans ces cas là
quand on se retrouve dans des plans à
peu quand on se fait serrer par les
keufs comme on dit on devient vite un
arabe tout de suite tout de suite ah
ouais tu te donnes a vu samy naceri là
là là je te retrouves avec les entraves
aux pieds les mains notamment dans la
cage sans chaussettes
et puis quand tu es dans le car est
content mène à l'hôpital pour voir si
tard elle n'était pas malade tu as une
bonne ronde geste sur la gueule et puis
on dit sale [ __ ] voilà c'est génial
ouais dites-le à la télé ça mais je
n'arrête pas de dire comment dites le
que quand vous êtes star samy naceri
tout le monde est sympa avec vous mais
dès que vous avez un petit problème avec
un chauffeur de taxi la nuit et puis
vous en payez un poste d'agent de police
on vous traite de nouveau comme un
[ __ ] ouais c'est vrai ben voila moi
je suis habillée par la redoute mais je
suis tranquille dans les commissariats
le rôle qu'est bien
alors comme on vient de le voir samy
naceri a eu des hauts et des bas dans sa
vie maintenant c'est le hall est ravi
pour lui
alors c'est normal on va les faire une
interview abendanon ne bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a bougé ça me sert j'ai regardé mais
j'ai compris un peu tard qu il fallait
pas bouger
on peut la revoir à leur faire de toute
façon voilà vous avez un flic qui lui
disent ne pas bien on va faire une
interview à tanda
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle a encore parlé
c'est toujours la même mademoiselle
quotas bien alors samy naceri interview
à peine d'arn c'est facile le plus le
mois à ce que vous préférez en vous ma
sincérité en amitié passant l'a vu avec
gilles de maistre c'est que là ce que
vous détestez en veut comment dire quand
on pardonne pas on a du mal à pardonner
aux gens quand ils font des erreurs avec
moi à quoi je sais pas comment on peut
tout pardonner difficilement
difficilement ouais vous faire chier
quoi ce que vous préférez dans le cinéma
se retrouver devant une caméra
bratton de direction ouais des fois
c'est long un bref et non surtaxé 1 il
ya 9 heures du matin ils attendaient
toute la journée pour conduire le taxi
et à 16 heures quand on l'enfilé là bas
il ya le fameux coup du viaduc qui est
dans le film d'action le vin viaduc qui
était pas fini de construire
il compte du sud comme une bête et il y
avait l'autre diefenthal du baratin et
ouvrait la porte ils essayent freiner
avec le pied le mec je me suis arrêté
bien avant quand même mais c'est
vraiment le truc le truc là où on voit
que frei ni les pros quoi c'est que tout
en ayant peur il voulait pas gâcher
apprise il voulait pas gâcher la scène
donc il ouvrait la porte il freinait
avec ses pieds il disait daniel quoi il
faisait tous amis oui c'est sa get up ce
que vous détestez dans le cinéma tu es
beau tu es gentil était génial
j'ai un peu dans tous les métiers quand
ma main et beaucoup dans le cinéma
beaucoup dans le cinéma le plus grand
moment de votre vie
la nomination aux césars les espoirs
puis la naissance de julian aussi bien
sur le pire le coupage de du film de la
mer ce qui vous fait le plus marrer dans
la vie mon frère ah oui ouais j'ai du
cinéma aussi ouais il écrit c'est un
comique n'est pas bon c'est un fou
furieux et c'est un cimetière et le
réveil c'est un fou furieux
qu'est ce qui vous fait le moins rire le
racisme l'endroit où vous rêveriez
d'être si vous étiez pas avec laurent et
moi et nos amis téléspectateurs avec
public ce soir avec marie dans un
plumard comme moi ce direct voilà un est
l'endroit où vous voudriez surtout pas
être derrière les barreaux les mecs qui
sont fermées en ce moment ce qui vous
aide à dormir le soir un bon lexomil
ouais c'est pas dangereux le non si ces
données si tu le prends avec modération
avec modération un pétard c'est pas
mieux
j'ai changé j'ai première l'a sollicité
alors oui c'est ça non
/ je connais une tonne l'adresse de
raymond barre à autre il venu c'est
l'opium a annoncé de trompe vraiment
bars et pas l'opium
c'est quoi non parce que j'ai bien vu
que
il ya confondues c'est de l'hélium qui
l'assumé alors si vous êtes à dormir
c'est un bon os x mobile avec
l'opération est ce qui peut vous
empêcher de dormir mari aussi et puis
way et puis une mauvaise journée c'est à
dire que je me suis pris la tête sur un
tournage et puis je suis pas content de
moi et je me refais les scènes 300 x 400
froid et puis marie à la bombe dire ça y
est c'est fini c'est dans la boîte pour
mort c'est fini maintenant faut que tu
remettre le gouvernement ça ça m'empêche
de dormir
marie est donc votre compagne et mon
amour voilà je le dis à nos amis
téléspectateurs ce qui vous excite le
plus chez une femme qu'elle est en vie
et kaka face celle qui a pas envie ah
c'est bien ça
tout alors
les excite ce qui vous excite le mois
une meuf vulgaire qui tease et qui pour
pour m'intimider ou pour me sort toutes
les cinq minutes des trucs comme on y
croise il boit en mangeant un truc juste
pour parce que je viens un peu de
banlieue et tout ça et puis qu'elle
essaye de jouer cette carte là ça m'est
arrivé plusieurs fois ou vulgaire quoi
un truc je joue un peu banlieues
populaires genre catherine deneuve
qu'est-ce que vous avez de plus sexy en
vous sami dans votre avis après
demandera aux filles soit je crois que
c'est mes yeux et puis la cicatrice les
yeux c'est vrai les yeux la cicatrice
tout à dieu merci merci mais n'est pas
sortie samiha prévision est excusé de
moins sexy
rien ils disent il ya bien quelque chose
de moins c'est que si je commence à
avoir la des trucs là mais non les
poignées d'amour way n'ont pas l'air
d'accord je crois qu'elle vous trouve
très sexy
merci au cinéma c'est normal de faire
quelques bides bon dernière question ce
que vous ce que vous préférez dans le
sexe la chose qui vous plaît le plus
dans le sexe forte ouais ouais
qu'est ce qui vous plaît le mois les
trucs attaché traces comme ça avec ma
chère maman écouter le salut je crois
que nous aurons jamais d'un monde
surtout il faut essayer pour savoir
enfin ce avait d'ailleurs non non j'ai
pas essayé mais
vous plaît pas toutes les perversions un
peu comme ça il ya des perversions qui
sont qui sont peu glissé et puis il ya
les pour essayer messahel truc juillet
machin les anneaux dans les salles mais
passe à saint louis leplée passe
non je préfère le côté tu flirter ça
part en sucette un moment donné les
cheveux c'est trop chaud c'est trop
chaud ça me vaut rester avec nous donc
j'aurai pro que ça vibre on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler donc le film
s'appelle là bas mon pays film
d'alexandre arcady avec antoine de co2
mathilda may le 12 avril et je vous
conseille d'aller le voir voilà alors
maintenant on va recevoir une chanteuse
est tout à fait étonnante parce qu'à
l'époque de céline dion de lara fabian
de mariah carey c'est vraiment un ovni
voici lynda lemay
bonsoir alors tout le monde parle de
vous c'est vrai qu'elle a c'est de plus
en plus ça marche fort ja revient passer
au dessus de nos espérances
grosse grosse arrivée de canadiennes ces
derniers temps et julie snyder en
pratique
lynda lemay oui non mais vraiment vous
êtes le talk of the town commande est
passée mais c'est sa cessé il ya deux
mois déjà sur la rue je me faisais pour
connaître du tout et c'est le mac avec
ma première tournée de spectacles avec
quelques émissions de bonnes émissions
de radio bonne émission de télé ça fait
par les normes et surtout de bonnes
chansons on va en écouter un petit peu
tout à l'heure et laurent ruquier sur
europe 1 a ordonné à ses auditeurs
d'acheter votre disque et la dga qui
s'appelle la et zoom zoom mon garçon
vous l'avez ordonné non j'ai lancé un
appel ce que je fais jamais à la radio
parce qu'on est tous là avant le dernier
disque de la chanteuse même si elle nous
fait chier ou si vous fait chier au foot
mais à leur acheter le disque et là je
me suis dit allez attention je vous dis
jamais ça mais le disque là c'est cet
après midi à 14h vous filez à la fnac
n'importe où et n'importe quel disque
disquaires à côté de chez vous et vous
allez l'acheter parce que c'est pas le
tout dire j'aime bien le disque j'aime
bien cette chanteuse je les applaudis
faut aller le mais la meilleure
récompense est d'aller acheter son
disque c'était très convaincant et les
jalons écouter quelle autorité gens qui
n'aiment pas mais non mais parce que ça
changeait un peu bien sûr c'est ce que
je vous ai québécois ça ressemble un peu
nous on n'a pas vu ça depuis marie paule
belle à peu près quoi donc votre disque
est 12e
une parade sixième à l'aller une
concurrence chez les découvreurs parce
que laurent ruquier vous a sûrement
beaucoup aidé mais enfin maintenant tu
participes à tout le monde dit alors
jasna jours
c'est vrai que vous avez des asthmes
amour ben oui une rencontre au festival
de jazz de montreux qui a été marquante
qui est tombé amoureux d'une de mes
chansons qui s'appelle la visite
et depuis ce temps là bon ben il y a
décidé de me conseiller un petit peu un
petit peu pour le choisit cela parce que
comme ça
j'ai comme une envie d'être
la mairie
ce type est un arrive à lui à ramer
je veux qu'on va arrêter de sonner qu'il
s'agisse d'un poids des nains de combis
tous les enfants ma mère
pourquoi
la linda lemay donc ça c'est la visite
on va écouter d'autres
d'autres experts d une chanson de lynda
lemay qui sont sur ce cd l'heureuse
nabour donc avec son jardin qui va venir
tout à l'heure lui aussi il dit qu'il a
fait beaucoup pour vous oui évidemment
ya écrit des textes sur moi et qu il
fallait que je me tienne la pète à
demain pour toi que ça influence était
très élogieux et alors il ya pascal
seront qui lui dis moi j'étais le
premier donc ruquier aznavour alexandre
jardin c'est pas vrai le premier c'était
moi c'est vrai la suisse est oui mais
c'est vrai il y est venu au québec et
entendu une chanson et c'est drôle parce
que la chanson fort auquel les gens
accrochent sait jamais la même lui
c'était le plus fort c'est mon père et
c'est la première chanson que pascal
sevran est entendue et il m'a fait des
émissions depuis ce temps là des
émissions de télé extraordinaire j'ai
jamais vu autant de quelques données
autant de place à un artiste une artiste
une émission c'était génial adopté c'est
une dalle mais vraiment on lui demande
un truc parce qu'il ya un truc aime à
raconter une fois qui est très drôle je
trouve c'est son rêve
je sais pas si elle l'a rencontrée
depuis c'était de rencontrer johnny
hallyday alors je sais cet après midi je
fais une sieste et j'ai fait un
cauchemar c'était que je le rencontrais
enfin et c'est exactement ce que je veux
pas qu'il se passe gtr rouge j'étais qui
c'est à dire que tu as comme on dit au
québec une vraie grosse épaisse rouge
que j'ai rencontré tout ce que je disais
c'est idiot et non c'est pas arrivé
encore ça aurait pu arriver parce que
dans les coulisses de chez drucker y est
arrivé pour parler à monsieur beer qui
était assis juste à côté de moi dans la
loge de coiffure je tenterai de me faire
coiffer déjà qu'on n'a pas l'air on a
l'air un peu imbécile quand on est en
train de se faire coiffer comme ça et il
s'est mis à parler ou monsieur moi
j'étais en train de faire une crise de
coeur et je pense que je ne voulais pas
cette aide est jazzy dans la gare je
sais que linda est une fan validé il ya
une chanson que vous aimez
particulièrement et puis elle aime
vraiment géniale idée parce qu'elle est
la sueur qui perlent sur le front c'est
cette chanson
c'est ce que vous écrivez ça n'a rien à
voir ça rien à voir parce que je serai
jamais capable faire ce qui fait je
devais rien et alain extraordinaire
c'est ma mère savait aussi assurer notre
chanson lynda lemay les souliers
soulié pas sur la
je les ai regardés semaine merci step à
la couette
j'vais les maires des gants vaisselle
pour ma part une saison dure quand je
suis arrivé dans la chambre les montrant
c'était comme un caméléon sur le livre
je t'ai demandé à qui s'était je peux
pas croire que tape bredouillé
exactement ce que je craignais
tu t'en avais aucune idée
d'une chanson ce n'est pas
autobiographique ça c'est une amie qui
vous la racontez ça c'est une autre
chose les filles avaient souillé d'une
autre femme dans un placard les souliers
verts j'aime bien tu étais comme un
caméléon sur le lit blanc cassé c'était
assez bien écrit le sait bien et on va
coûter encore encore une c'est celle
qu'on entend beaucoup quand même à la
radio même si vos chansons sont un peu
longue pour passer en radio on l'entend
[Musique]
paquet
quina des illusions et non des
tractations secrètes
son timbre fête locale 10 avril sa
manière la dernière tournée ça se passe
tellement bien depuis le tout début de
la tournée que j'imagine qu'on va avoir
beaucoup de mal et l'a bien alors comme
vous êtes québécoise je vais vous faire
une interview québec on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
personne n'a bougé quelle discipline et
sa bonne heure alors j'ai posé des
questions aux québécois donc samedi ça
va vous sûrement comme à moi vous parce
que vous allez parler québécois je vais
poser des questions avec des mots
québécois de dans ok est ce que votre
homme est plus qu tu que moi ça veut
dire est ce que ton petit ami et plus
mignon que moi c'est ce qu'il souhaite
la s'est passé c'est un jeu parle plus
vraiment de ma vie privée parce que
l'eau j'ai eu trop de problèmes avec ça
au québec donc ici j'ai fait de tenir ce
au plus pressé mais vous allez le
reconnaître qu'il ya les plus beaux yeux
tous les hommes sont de série est-ce que
vous avez déjà avalé un sous marin ouais
c'est très bon avec beaucoup de
pepperoni de fromage souvent est ce
pareil c'est comme ici tout à fait ceux
des sandwichs pense finalement alors
cessé des baguettes de pain avec est ce
que vous aimez turluter dans votre salle
de bain c'est rare que je tire l'être
mais j'aimerais pouvoir le faire
sérénité vous savez ce que ça veut dire
lutter dans votre salle de bain c'est
vrai rires vous et vous monsieur lutte
et non pas encore cannes est une
traduction française qui est drôle
d'être sur le terrain allant d'une pizza
saurait
oui
et ça veut dire pas laurent au québec là
tu vas te dirai ce que je sais faire
chanter tranchantes et je tuerai tous
les matins est-ce que vous avez déjà
agacé une toune moi ga cet automne mais
igor agar les poteaux mais aussi
d'efficacité toutoune ah ouais mais une
toute grosse fille mais c'est une
question de postiers dans ce n'est que
ça veut dire draguer abou dagga c'est
une toune on va le savourer draguer un
laideron est ce que vous êtes fait
souvent fourré nous élus québécois
quand on fait cette carrière cerbère à
voir mais c'est dans les deux sens au
québec donc fo unsa bonne posture pour
les deux sens était donc c est ce que
vous êtes déjà tapé la foufoune voilà la
foule chez deyris et l'a fait sinon
c'est bien je sais que c'est devant
ardisson quand même avant vraiment alors
j'ai de la mémoire mais je sais pas
embauché à cannes c'est pas français
dont coraline et lumière lynda lemay
donc le 10 avril à l'olympia
[Applaudissements]
alors tout le monde parle de l'élection
la mairie de paris
donc j'ai accueilli maintenant le
directeur des affaires politiques auprès
de michèle alliot marie
j'accueille et lycra hoult
avec raul bonsoir soir donc vous êtes
vous mesurer à m 90 un peu moins un peu
moi mais je pèse un peu plus peser un
peu plus sans qu'il honore mais bon je
crois vous aviez maigri oui mais j'ai
vraiment vous étiez à 104 me dites pas
que vous êtes toujours à 104 je suis
monté au dessus non cités les fatigue et
puis c'est les échecs électoraux avant
ça fait grossir les échecs électoraux
comme les soucis c'est que pour ça on se
demandait pourquoi s'il va bouffer tous
les mardis avec michèle alliot marie à
l'elysée on connaît la teneur des
déjeuners de chirac qui va vite prendre
du poids réel aussi d'ailleurs dans six
mois c'est madeleine albright elle a du
poids politique mais elle a une ligne
que l'on suit là à ça c'est pas mal
trouvé pas mal trouvé c'est bien que ça
commençait alors cet ancien ministre
vous êtes maire du raincy vous êtes
conseiller régional ile-de-france
secrétaire national du apaire et comme
je les dis directeur des affaires
politiques auprès de michèle alliot
marie
donc là vous avez un souci en ce moment
c'est à dire que la date rang delanoë a
résumé la situation sur la mairie de
paris il a dit c'est plus des primaires
c'est un annuaire il ya ce lien là
peut-être oublié de dire quelque chose
c'est cuit les candidats tout seul
oui parce que pour éviter qu'ils aient
deux candidats on a offert le ministère
de l'éducation nationale jack lang
oui en fait chaque langue il y avait
déjà été à l'éducation nationale donc
c'est pas non plus une aberration dans
les années 80 il craque
il ya 20 ans c'est vrai que chirac peut
pas en faire autant d'aléas l'éducation
nationale de nommer des ministres en ce
moment alors les candidats ya tiberi
tiberi j'imagine quand même que le rpr a
essayé de trouver du boulot ailleurs
pour qu'il s'en aille pourquoi vous
n'arrivez pas à le faire partir de là
bâti berry il a fait un mandat
oui elle est pas résidents sont pas si
mécontent que sa demande à la difficulté
c'est qu'il ya eu des problème c'est
qu'il ya eu des affaires et c'est que
même si c'est injuste on n'est pas
propriétaire d'un mandat il revient pas
à son parti mehal électoral décidé il ya
quatre candidats aujourd'hui c'est pas
nous qui les avons suscité
mais bon si on disait il en faut un
on dirait c'est une caserne il y en a
quatre ont dit c'est le bazar
alors bon on va essayer de régler ça se
gagne
résistant je trouve tiberi parce que
quand même trois candidats face à lui il
faut le faire mais ils étaient
résistants pour la garder jal yahia se
guérit j'ai l'impression que tu coupes
la tête et la queue qui bouge encore
c'est assez fou il ya ce gain il ya
balladur il ya françoise de panafieu et
à tiberi ça fait 4 vous j'étais je sais
pas aujourd'hui mais jusque là c'était
plutôt françoise de panafieu votre
préférée non ben il ya des candidats de
poids
et puis il ya une candidate de charme
trop le poids il charme choisi ouais
mais michèle alliot marie va choisir
comment sérieusement parce que c'est pas
facile là entre monstres françoise de
panafieu ou encore on peut y écouter
gentil tu étais plus jeune témoin mais
entre se gagnent en sérieux entre seguin
et balladur c'est ça va être terrible
pour michèle alliot marie de choisir
parce que c'est quand même deux poids
lourds seguin balladur surtout ce gars
mais elle avait dit on va les mettre sur
la ligne de départ on ne les met dans
les starting blocks
et puis après on évite qui se balancent
des coups de pied dans les tibias
c'est réussi on va leur proposer
d'exposer leurs projets mais ce que
michèle alliot marie dit c'est pas à moi
de trancher
on doit définir un profil avec les
parisiens parce que c'est eux qui vont
choisir c'est pas les journalistes c'est
pas autre chose que de décider quand
andre myhrer des élections surtout les
gens qui ont une carte du rpr à paris un
jour vont être appelés à voter pour
choisir le candidat ça sera pas tout à
fait comme ça parce que si ces pratiques
alors si si on faisait ça on sera obligé
de le faire partout meilleur puisqu'il
ya trente-six mille huit cent trente
trois communes en france et y en a 36
1832 qui ont pas envie que ça se passe
comme ça mais qui va faire le choix
parce que vous nous dites que c'est pas
les c'est pas les membres du rpr à paris
qui va choisir
il y aura les élus il y aura les
militants et puis y aura aussi les
projets ils vont présenter chacun ce
qu'ils veulent faire pour paris je vais
pas me mêler de nos affaires mais ça
ressemble un peu à l'élection de miss
france sur tf1 l'a fait on sait jamais
on ne sait jamais qui veulent bien si
c'est l'essence si c'est miss france ça
sera peut-être miss paris ouais vous
l'aimez un panafieu aussi remarqué un
bain j'avais cru comprendre mais bon
pour autant et à tiberi ya balladur il
ya ce gain est pas sorti de l'auberge
j'ai hâte de voir bella dire en campagne
oui non parce qu'il est génial doudou
en campagne sur les marchés quand il
tente les melons avec ses gants en août
quand il descend dans le métro à chaque
campagne électorale balladur descendre
dans le métro pour faire un peu pop la
dernière fois était descendu à la
station louvre les gens ont cru qu'une
statue avait bougé applaudie par ci par
là qu'il est il paraît qu'il n'est pas
paris il à chamonix ce week end edouard
balladur c'est vrai il a une maison de
campagne la main et c'est un aubergiste
qui l'a reconnu à varennes au québec
mais les choses bien alors on va parler
un peu de vous eric raoult août
donc en 1972 1973
vous participez à un mouvement en faveur
d'un prof qui a été arrêté vous
manifester et vous apercevez que en fait
tout ce mouvement de protestation pour
soutenir ce prof arrêté a été en fait
manipuler par le parc kruger prof
proches du parti communiste et là vous
vous dites je me suis fait blouser et
vous passer carrément de l'autre côté
c'est vrai il y avait des étudiants des
lycéens des profs qui disait faut la
paix au vietnam
il disait il faut que la guerre s'arrête
et puis le jour où ils se sont aperçus
qu'il fallait que la guerre continue
ils ont oublié ce qu'ils avaient dit
auparavant et puis j'avais un pote dans
ma classe il était vietnamien et un jour
on l'a plus vu pendant trois jours on a
cru qu'il était malade il était chez lui
parce que sa famille avait été massacrée
à huer
ce jour là je me suis dit il faut
choisir faut s'engager et je sais pas ce
que j'aurais fait si c'était un pote
communiste qui avait eu sein d'un mois
j'ai passé carrément d'un côté à droite
vers ce que dit jean d'ormesson il dit
que le drame du 20e siècle a été d'être
obligé de choisir entre deux
totalitarismes
vous avez choisi les comités de soutien
au sud vietnam et donc vous êtes
retrouvé embarqué avec des gens de
droite voire d'extrême droite à ce
moment là j'étais pas coco ça m'embêtait
d'être fachos suis devenu gaulliste
c'est pas si mal parce que je suis resté
dans un engagement qui me permettait à
gaulliste quand même et gaullistes de
droite parce que plutôt munichois
oui c'était pas aussi des gaullistes de
gauche capitan sera gaulliste de gauche
vous étiez plutôt gaulliste de droite
oui c'était plutôt beau liste
bien à droite que pour moi bon ben on
n'a pas à avoir honte de ce que l'on
peut dire mais tout en respectant les
autres
vous disiez à l'époque que leur ainsi
donc la ville dont vous êtes le maire
aujourd'hui était le 51e état soviétique
c'était vraiment un fief des bonnes
choses là bas ma commune non le
département de la seine-saint-denis oui
puisqu'on est jumelée avec la corée du
nord est avec la banlieue de la havane
ah oui alors évidemment pour tout dire
pour partir en vacances en corée du nord
il n'y a pas beaucoup de volontaires
faut le faire et la banlieue de la
havane depuis de castro y est ça fait
quand même des problèmes et je connais
vallier dares moi aussi oui alors donc
après bon ben voila vous vous rentrez en
politique de cette façon là vous devenez
un apparatchik du rpr voilà est alors en
85 ce délégué national à la jeunesse et
la tenez vous bien vous vous déclarez
jeunes tous bonne east alors j'aimerais
savoir parce que moi je vous cloue les
jeunes giscardiens temps des jeunes
giscardiens bon encore jeremy hunt ou
bouddhistes qu'est ce que tout bon et
l'idéologie d'un jeune tout beau nist
n'ont jamais devant un bolivien ça
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
l'embolie ces chauffeurs de salle donc
tu te demandes ce que tout bon il avait
été choisi par chirac pour être
secrétaire général du rpr et en 1982
c'est lui qui réussit à garder la mairie
du 13e il succède à bernard pons et
c'est un peu le chef des jeunes
gaullistes bon hier il y avait marché ya
robert hue nous on avait eu poncet il ya
eu tout bon et puis ensuite il a été
remplacé par juppé c'est pas si si drôle
que ce à quoi tout le moins il a été
d'abord ministre de la culture est
ensuite remis nistre la justice c'est
moi je le préférais la culture plutôt
que la justice parce que la culture est
lui en était sûrs qu'ils étaient
indépendants bien monde un groupe comme
ça boume est au courant on continue avec
vous eric raoult en 1988
oui vous envoyer une lettre à vos
électeurs potentiels et vous leur dites
nous à vous expliquer un vouloir dit
notre france à nous jeunes tous bonne
east ce n'est pas celle des tibaous ce
n'est pas celle de françoise sagan ce
n'est pas celles d'harlem désir ce n'est
pas celle de krasucki c'est la france
immortel de jeanne d'arc de charles
martel de napoléon et de gaulle alors la
france n'est pas un ramassis de
socialistes qui font passer la défense
des étrangers des délinquants des
drogués avant l'amour de la france
alors moi je peux vous dire générer un
conte de charles martel contre jeanne
d'arc contre de gaulle napoléon un peu
plus mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on qu'il
faut dire que krasucki c'est pas la
france que françoise sagan c'est pas la
france c'est un peu des relents des
années 30 avec l'anti france va écouter
dans une vie politique comme dans une
vie tout court on dit un certain nombre
de bêtises on fait des conneries là
j'avoue que le truc que j'ai écrit
c'était plutôt dans une campagne
électorale et ce papier là je le
publierai pas dans mes oeuvres choisies
ça vous choque ça samy naceri quand
vous entendez choses comme ça là les
maghrébins les blacks les italiens les
portugais les hindous ils font marcher
le business français il n'y a pas de des
dealers n'y a pas que des voleurs il ya
des mecs qui se tape tous les jours qui
vont travailler qui ramène de l'argent
et qu'ils sont là mais je dis que à un
moment donné il ya eu un truc qui a
couru comme quoi on pouvait faire voter
les étrangers et qui ceux qui avaient
des papiers étrangers au moins ils
pourraient être votées dans leurs
circonscriptions dans les mairies au
raincy à nogent tissier palais municipal
donc je sais pas où ça en est mais ça
sera intéressant de que que tous ces
gens là qui font marcher le business qui
se lèvent le matin à cette pompe du mat
et qui font marcher les métros les bus
carnas les poubelles plus ça puisse
aussi voter et pourquoi pas voter pour
le président de la république je sais
pas on n'y est pas encore arrivé en tous
les cas nous djamel bouras jamel
debbouze tous ces mecs là zidane on se
barre on se bat pour pour pour la france
moi tant que je vais défendre un film je
le défends mon film pour la france j'ai
rencontré la dernière fois d'aider des
gens pour pour taxi ont chanté la
marseillaise pour rigoler je suis
français vous savez durant les années 80
et 90 notre pays n'était pas prêt et à
chaque fois que françois mitterrand
relançait ses idées ça faisait monter le
pen alors le pen y en a un coup sur la
tête ne le réveillon pas faisons en
sorte qu' on puisse promouvoir
l'acquisition de la nationalité
française
calmement gentiment et puis qu'il ya un
beaucoup plus grand nombre de français
qui puissent voter et à ce moment là
comme ils ont la carte d'identité
ils ont le bulletin de vote bien en
continu avec vous donc on continue parce
que s'ils voulaient moi je suis pour la
transparence c'est moi j'ai rien contre
vous mais il ya des choses que
vous avez fait dans votre carrière je
suis obligé de vous parler dont vous
étiez par exemple ami avec roger
holeindre violence comme un dur du fn
votre suppléant c'est pierre bernard
pierre bernard il a quand même été
condamné pour injure raciale bon vous
l'avez laissé tomber c'est vrai que le
jour où les assister aux obsèques du
milicien paul touvier vous l'avez laissé
tomber ce bernard pas faisait quand même
eu des mauvaises fréquentations
non ça c'est pas vous nous disiez tout à
l'heure oui c'était l'époque du vietnam
tout ça et c'est vrai que le vietnam
quand tout le monde a applaudi le jour
où les viet minh son entrée dans ses
gonds 75 ridicule on s'est tous bons
mais vous ça c'était après quand même
l'époque où ces 88 89 vous fréquentiez
des gens comme pierre bernard comme
roger holeindre roger holeindre c'est
popeye c'est un ancien combattant marron
il a dit des bêtises et il a rejoint le
pen ce qui à mon avis est une preuve
qu'il n'a pas laissé tomber le fait
qu'il ya quand même un truc qui est
gênant chez le pen c'est que il peut
dire tout ce qu'il veut sur plein de
sujets quand il devient raciste
xénophobe et antisémite on peut pas
l'accepter
pour ce qui concerne pierre bernard mon
suppléant il est maire d'une ville
montfermeil et c'est dans ma
circonscription
quand pierre bernard disait qu dans
cette circonscription est dans sa ville
il y avait des difficultés avec une cité
qui s'appelle les bosquets où il ya
beaucoup d'insécurité c'était vrai et
quand il est allé aux obsèques de paul
touvier on a divorcé alors en 95 vous
devenez ministre de l'intégration du
gouvernement juppé alors là voilà vous
proposez là vous remettez en question le
rmi en disant que la culture et rémy
c'est la culture de l'inactivité
mais vous croyez pas quand même
sérieusement je veux dire c'est vrai
qu'à peut-être des gens qui touchent le
rmi et qu'ils foutent rien enfin
franchement quand on en est à toucher le
rmi on commençait minimum quoi tirèrent
10 sont si vous aviez été à nantes a
écouté le président de la république
il a dit ça avec les mots d'un président
c'est à dire qu' il faut que les
titulaires du rmi fasse des efforts
d'insertion et ne reste pas dans je
dirais uniquement les trames de
l'exclusion
alors ya le style raul tu es il ya le
propos présidentiel
moi j'ai voulu cogner pour réveiller
pour dire aux gens attendent et on peut
pas continuer comme ça on avait inventé
le rmi pour 190 mille personnes on en a
bientôt neuf cent mille ce que j'ai
voulu dire c'est que quand on a le rmi
il faut aussi essayer d'entrer dans une
approche qui vous permet de vous en
sortir
et pas uniquement dans l'élite ce soir
en gros quand même c'est que vous avez
écrit cette fameuse lettre en 88 vous
avais tes copains avec bernard vous avez
dit ça sur les régimes et finalement
vous n'êtes pas si méchant que ça vous
l'apprécierez comme vous voudrez non
parce que vous demandiez aussi de le
déplacement des familles de délinquants
alors ça je comprends ça aussi bondi il
ya des familles dans certaines cités qui
vraiment les parents tiennent depuis les
enfants ils foutent la merde il faut les
déplacer
enfin bon c'est quand même le doigt dans
un drôle d'engrenages salon le cd portée
des gens j'ai fait du chemin
d'abord j'ai fait du chevénement avant
l'heure moi j'avais pas dit sauvageons
j'avais dit ça ce que je me suis aperçu
simplement c'est que bien souvent quand
on parle d'un problème il faut le vivre
et il faut essayer de le résoudre
quand on parle du problème des banlieues
en habitant dans le xvième où à neuilly
mais marche pas will it d'ailleurs il
n'habite pas à cintegabelle ou à l'hôtel
matignon vous dit c'est pas faux et en
fonction de ça je peux vous assurer que
dans une cité tout le monde se tient à
carreau et qu'on peut pas simplement
faire des mesures pour ceux qui
pourrissent la vie des autres alors
quand vous étiez au gouvernement ont
toujours devient inventé le plan vigie
casseurs d'ailleurs françois hollande
avait parlé de vous en disant que
c'était plutôt le plan vigie gaffeur et
juppé lui l'a fait le plan vizir ondina
prévu vous parlez d'intifada concernant
les banlieues faut quand même pas
exagérer non plus mais bon quand on a
parlé pendant mes de plan marshall plan
marshall c'est un plan qui a été enfin
c'est le plan de l'aide américaine à la
france après la guerre la deuxième
guerre mondiale
ces banlieues c'est pas l'intifida c'est
pas les banlieues sont pas détruites au
point d'avoir besoin d'un plan marshall
faut faire attention au pouvoir des mots
non thierry pour ce qui concerne les
événements faut s'en souvenir
les bagnoles qui brûlait des policiers
qui tirait il a fallu calmer tout ça et
si c'est pas moi qui ai parlé de plan
marshall
le plan marshall c'était mettre beaucoup
d'argent pour essayer de nous offrir et
une mauvaise mais le nom plan marshall
vous rendez compte
le plan marshall c'était quelqu'un qui
est pas franchement rpr qui s'appelle
adil jazouli qui est maintenant les
conseillers de martine aubry qui l'avait
proposé je vais pas payer de droits
d'auteur bien alors ce qui s'est passé
pour finir ces quinze jours il ya eu 7
ce qu'on appelait la ferc lavergnée de
vous connaissez tavernier célèbre
réalisateur de cinéma manifestent contre
la loi debré vous dites vous écoutez
venez habiter un mois au quartier des
grands péchés à montreuil c'est ça et en
fait lui il a demandé à son fils nils
tavernier de faire un documentaire qui
s'appelle de l'autre côté du périph et
finalement à la sortie de quoi on
s'aperçoit c'est que ces gens-là ils
sont présentés comme des méchants en
fait ne sont que des malheureux
vous vous êtes catholique raout oui nous
ne comprenez ce que je veux dire oui
quand on est catholique
on va à la messe mais on s'est parfois
aussi se retrousser les manches pour
aider tout le monde mais pas simplement
pour fermer les yeux sur un certain
nombre de problèmes
là il s'agissait pas de montrer du doigt
certains on avait un problème de sans
papiers il n'y avait pas d'un côté les
sans papiers de l'autre les sans pitié
il ya dans ce pays
un très grand nombre de personnes qui
sont en situation irrégulière si vous et
moi thierry on se retrouvait à new york
demain sans papiers on se ferait virer
un ben oui je suis déjà fait virer mois
pour 2 grammes de shit donc oui c'est
tir manque
six pays de merde si on se retrouvait
dans une situation d'irrégularité
je crois que le mieux dans ce pays c'est
qu'on parle clairement on a une
population importante à intégrer et qui
s'intègre plutôt bien et qui fait des
réussites n'a lourdes ont pas n'alourdit
sont pas le bateau dans la mesure où au
bout du compte après on donne des
vitamines à l'extrême droite sans régler
les problèmes
lorsque vous dites là c'est finalement
vous êtes un homme de bonne volonté
j'essaye d'être d'abord un homme de
volonté c'est à dire de vouloir faire
bouger un certain nombre de choses et
puis je me suis aperçu souvent que y'en
a marre de ceux qui parlent des
problèmes sans connaître moi les ogm ou
les problèmes agricoles je sais pas je
m'arrêtais or j'ai l'impression parfois
que bertrand tavernier
une fois qu'ils avaient filmé le mur au
péché c'est à dire un quartier difficile
de montreuil
il rentrait dans son hôtel particulier
son fils il a comme moi j'ai tourné avec
son fils dernièrement donc je connais
bien je connais pas le père mais je
connais bien le fils ils ont quand même
rester je crois qu'ils sont assez de
trois mois au grand péché moi j'ai
grandi mon grand péché à côté j'ai
grandi j'ai grandi à la zup mois à côté
un peu plus bas avant que moi je connais
bien je connais bien le beller et je
connais bien toutes ces sites est là et
je vous garantis que moi je suis parti
il n'y a pas longtemps j'étais encore il
ya trois jours avec des copains à côté
et quand je suis passé en voiture parce
que j'ai grandi là et c'était ma société
rien qu'à changer ils ont mis trois
trucs des escaliers et des machins pour
les mots mon copain il faisait déjà ma
fille à la crèche là et rien du tout les
monde je passe en attaque si génial la
musique et tout ils ont deux trois bus
et des machins s'est pas seulement de
foot début et aidé m 2 3 trucs machins
faut qu'il ya un réel truc alors que ce
soit la droite la gauche je sais pas
mais qu'il ya une vraie volonté que
d'aider les mecs pour qu'il s'en sorte
parce qu'il n'ya pas que des il ya des
mecs qui font de la musique il ya des
mecs qui sortent et qui font du sport il
ya des vrais mecs qu'on la volonté mais
compaq ont pas encore fait le pas parce
qu'ils n'ont pas été à l'école parce que
ils sont avec les potes à la sortie
devant les sites et à fumer du shit et
puis s'en foutent
mais s'il ya un vrai truc si un vrai
machin il ya moyen il n'y a pas que des
il n'y a pas que des cas là il n'y a pas
que dd
des mecs qui vont faire des braquages
toute leur vie c'est parce que j'ai
voulu dire c'est pas ce qu'il a dit moi
j'habite dans le 17e avant j'habitais à
la zup à côté de la statue encore des
grands péchés on habitait à cette dent
aujourd'hui je les gagne et ça je me
suis tapé j'ai touché le rmi mois
pendant cinq ans je me levais le matin
je regardais les boulangeries et j'avais
pas 5 francs pour m'acheter un pain au
chocolat
je me suis battu aujourd'hui je suis
acteur j'arrive à nourrir ma famille je
fais pas de politique je vais peut-être
entrer dans les trucs que je vais pas
contrôler mais j'espère que vous ferez
autant de choses même si eux ils se
plantent et qui font des conneries c'est
vous les politiques qui avaient été
annulés mais avant de faire cette
émission finalement si on retrace votre
carrière ardisson l'a fait vous avez
donc dit beaucoup de conneries vous avez
eu de mauvaises fréquentations et vous
avez été souvent maladroit est ce que
pendant cette émission fait vôtre mais
récupère tout mea culpa tout de suite
comme ça on est tranquille vous avez
aussi dit des conneries
vous avez été maladroit et il m'avait eu
une mauvaise fréquentation j'ai essayé
d'être sincère parce que dans le passé
parfois je me suis fait fourrer et c'est
là c'est là que vous nous dites que se
faire fourrer c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
croit bon de terminer de cette façon
non il ya un truc avec vous la seule
chose qu'on peut dire c'est que il ya
quelqu'un qui a été naturalisé en quinze
jours en lice et évite les cheveux celui
qui sait c'est andreï makine lui il a eu
le prix goncourt et le prix médicis la
même année donc il a été naturalisé par
vos services en quinze jours ça veut
dire que pour être naturalisé rapidement
il faut avoir deux prix littéraires
damas non non non c'est pas c'est pas ça
je vais vous expliquer comment ça s'est
passé
il est allé sans papiers il est allé la
préfecture il est allé à la préfecture
de paris
il a fait sa lettre il s'est exprimé et
le type qui était là lui a dit c'est
bizarre c'est trop bien écrit et
l'écriture est trop belle ça doit être
un faux ouais donc on a essayé de
récupérer ça le président de la
république avait été informé et j'ai
demandé à mes collaborateurs d'aller
plus vite mais les quinze jours
c'est ça qu'il faudrait avoir c'est à
dire que l'on puisse non pas attendre un
an deux ans ou trois ans pour obtenir la
naturalisation
parce que quand on a une origine
étrangère et qu'on veut choisir la
france faudrait que ça aille plus vite
bon bah merci en tous les cas de votre
franchise maintenant je vais vous faire
une interview
hull c'est pas fini nathan a tous je
m'attends à tout vient de dire eric
raoult l'edt et vous ne saviez pas ce
qu'elle est vous arrivez vous êtes prêts
oui interview nul vraiment que des
questions qu'on compte 6 ou réponse à
vous est ce que voulais la justice et
rien est ce que vous préférez votre père
ou votre mère plutôt ma mère est ce que
vous préférez hitler ou staline ni l'un
ni l'autre
alors si vous deviez vous réincarner s
couvre un quart ne riez en arêtes
laguiller simone veil
edith cresson ou marie france stirbois
plutôt simone veil plutôt simone veil
parce que c'est une sacrée bonne femme
est ce que vous feriez si vous étiez sur
une île déserte
est ce que vous feriez plus facilement
l'amour avec une fille très laide ou un
mec très beau niverville au nom me dites
pas ça on ne sait trop de moins - hitler
staline je veux bien encore on prend je
viens vous utilisez votre jeune carrière
d'un truc à 3 non non non vous en
sentirez pas comme ça quand on est dans
la politique
bon on peut discuter là on répond alors
la nana très laide avant une nana très
lettre plutôt qu'un mec très beau way is
it a du toupet des veaux non mais ça
veut dire que l'on attendait en tout cas
pas au public non je suis pas comme ça
quoi du tout du tout non mais vous avez
pas parce qu'on a tous une partie
masculin femina vous pas du tout jamais
jamais jamais essayé j'ai jamais fumé
j'ai jamais essayé jamais fumé de nom
mais par rapport à ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure c'est à dire qu'il ya des
trucs qu'on fait ou des trucs qu'on fait
pareil bon ben ça j'ai jamais fait bon
bah donc vous le savez si vous êtes
tentés vous pouvez écrire à la
production de l'émission qui transmettra
surtout si vous avez envie de vous taper
eric raoult
moi je suis louer une idée
oui pour les gonzesses moche c'est une
bonne idée bien vous accorderiez plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites jeunes
où un jeune qui tapent sur des petites
vieilles voilà c'est vraiment content à
question très confiant le jeune qui
tapent sur des petites vieilles c'est un
lâche 1
l'autre c'est un type qui se trompe et
qui veut pas vieillir ouais donc vous
avez plus chaque enseigne landes pour le
vieux qui sape des petites jeunes
ouais parce qu'il ya 44 ans je suis plus
tout jeune prépare l'avenir c'est dur en
même temps 44 ans est rien il ya un ami
qui débarque chez vous à l'improviste
qu'est-ce qui nous fournit le plus honte
qu'ils trouvent sur votre table de nuit
mein kampf ou un godemiché j'ai pas mein
kampf suivant et franchement j'ai pas de
godemichet non plus à bord mais j'ai un
bureau m'allonger la messe qui vous
feriez non c'est un jeu de l'esprit ce
qui me ferait on s'est mal quand vous le
godemiché le plus hot
gmail com vous pourrez dire bon je suis
pas nazi mais je le lis pas ce qu'il
faut l'avoir lu il faut avoir tout lu
donc moi c'est vraiment une question
piège qui réside à je sais où danger
c'est d'avoir comment un certain nombre
de bouquins mais mein kampf
j'ai vu dans une bibliothèque je les ai
pas lues et un godemichet il m'est
arrivé des fois d'en voir dans des
magazines mais j'en ai jamais acheter y
a pas grande différence finalement parce
que dans les deux cas on l'a dans le cul
voilà donc vous n'avez jamais fumé de
pétards s'est jamais tapé deux garçons
vous n'êtes jamais utiliser de
godemichés nom faisait beaucoup de
choses à apprendre encore je vais vous
lire votre éducation et tester leurs
noms ont fait une offre après après
yassa
oui
là
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande de vous arrêter
tapie attentats puis sur un truc et tous
déclenché
c'est simple et efficace assez
extraordinaire c'est pas tout le monde
me demande pourquoi je suis pas aller
sur tf1 en vérité c'est pour pas
abandonner mon sampler bien alors eric
raoult août la bombe arrive dans 5
minutes vous faites quoi
la bombe atomique c'est la fin du monde
fait quoi bon ben j'essaie de faire
l'amour une dernière fois non je croyais
qu'il allait répondre je lis mein kampf
est demandée car pardon à catherine où
il ya catherine barba qui est très déçue
elle me dit dans l'oreillette il fait
l'amour en cinq minutes
alors est ce que vous seriez prêt va
souhaite un homme de bonne volonté à
échanger de et le choix on vous dit
voilà si vous acceptez vous eric raoult
et d'être paralysé jusqu'à la fin de vos
jours
kadri fric sur un lit mais il ya plus de
famine en ethiopie j'ai actuellement un
un pote qui est paralysé ouais et
j'essaierai plutôt de me dire comment je
pourrais faire pour donner un organe
pour le sauver c'est à dire d'avoir une
action pour quelqu'un d'autre pour pas
montrer que je suis égoïste mecs eu au
fond de moi-même généreux pour quelqu'un
que je connais parce que ceux qui disent
qu'ils seraient prêts être pas je serais
pour des millions de gens qui
connaissent pas je suis pas sûr que
c'est sincère
mais moi je sais quand j'ai écrit la
question je me suis posé la question
c'est quoi ta réponse j'avoue
franchement je le dis parce que j'essaye
d'être sincère c'est vrai qu'être
paralysé jusqu'à la fin de mes jours
c'est terrible le pire c est paralysé en
ethiopie
bon alors on va revenir à des choses un
peu plus on est tous les deux dans un
chalet
ça y est c'est reparti et moi je meurs
et commence plutôt parler plus sortir du
chalet parce que de la neige est une
tempête de neige c'est un je me faisais
plus rien à manger
vous êtes obligé de me manger moi vous
commencez par quoi qui a dit les fesses
vous commencez par quoi vous manger quoi
en premier chez moi je franchement moi
je fête vous je commencerai par les
couilles parce que d'autres les ont déjà
goûté avant alors que vous avez de la
chance d'avoir une dernière question
allez je vais te dire la langue a comme
ça je pourrai plus parler non non je
suis motard et bien oui d'accord je suis
mort dernière question quel est l'animal
qui embrasse le mieux
je dis une chose c'est que josé bové a
trouvé la réponse à cette question
l'éléphant non le tapir non la femme
voilà on rallume la lumière
j'accueille maintenant julie depardieu
bonsoir comment ça va ça va ça va normal
normal quoi mais je sens je sens votre
parfois jusqu ici c'est vrai je trouve
c'est quoi comme ça c'est des muscs
blancs
ouais ouais tu sens amis ça fait neuf
ans qu'on sentait du rpr bon julie vous
avez été remarqué dans l'examen de
minuit de danièle dubroux qui était
votre premier premier rôle
oui et vous êtes assez simple vous êtes
cool mais ça dépend ouais
jusqu'à présent j'ai toujours beaucoup
vous dit de toute façon je voulais pas
être la fille 2 je voulais pas ramener
ma fraise mais m'écraser non plus sous
prétexte de pas la ramener donc nous un
comportement assez assez ça normal même
si c'est compliqué vous avez un
comportement assez sain par rapport à ça
vous dit après tout ça c'est une assez
jolie phrase vite après tout je ne suis
que la rencontre d'un spermatozoïde une
ovules la wii va comme tout le monde
oui pardon je suis pas hyper bavarde
mais ça va venir
on a indiqué vous dites moi j'ai bossé
chez un copain fleuriste et quand on se
lève tous les matins à 5 heures pour la
à rungis s'armer à limbé ça mais c'était
déjà le montrent pas la tête c'est ça
que j'essaie de dire non mais la fleur
moi j'aime la fleur vous n'êtes pas
bluffé par le métier d'actrice et ce
parfum ça quelles fleurs mais non passer
du muscle ça sent très bon vous le
sentez nice je le sens bien sûr
j'aimerais vivre
et c'est vrai non je dis vous n'êtes pas
bluffé par le métier d'actrice mais
pourtant une carrière qui commence à se
dessiner
quand même la main pouvoir sais pas je
n'y croyais pas plus que ça bah si mais
ou non ouais il ya une réponse s'élève
de roland dubillard qui dit oui mais non
ouais voilà donc c'est oui mais non les
ménages baissaient pour connaissez samy
naceri non je n'essaie croisé déjà une
fois ou deux mais on n'a jamais tourné
en c3 à acapulco mais je crois que ça de
façon chacun tout à coup sûr est que non
non non
mais est ce soir là c'était acapulco
bien alors à parler d'un film donc dans
lequel vous avez à nouveau le premier
rôle qui s'appelle in extremis bien
alors c'est un film d'étienne fort avec
vous donc et sébastien roch
si jean claude brialy ça sort le 19
avril c'est ça
19 avril alors l'histoire je vous la
racontez vous me direz si je me trompe
pas le pas l'histoire parce que c'est
pas bien de raconter les histoires des
films et l'esprit le pitch c'est des
enfants de parents des barricades qui
part en conf et 68
c'est une génération qui a cinquantaine
d'années aujourd'hui qui après s'est
bien amusé et s'est jeté sur le pouvoir
et l'argent
et c'est une génération qui n'a pas bien
su s'occuper de ses enfants parce que
elle voulait s'amuser alors ça donne des
enfants sans repère un peu comme ceux
dont michel houellebecq parle dans les
particules élémentaires un peu toute
cette pipe
cette idée que finalement 68 qui a été
vécu à l'époque par les gens de ma
génération comme quelque chose
d'extraordinaire finalement on se rend
compte que c'était très égoïste et
finalement
les enfants enfin nos enfants en ont
souffert
et c'est des enfants qui sont
aujourd'hui sans autorité un petit peu
un petit peu à l'abandon
je prends pas du bien parce qu'ils sont
hauts comme ça mais je parle de ceux qui
sont plus âgés donc dans le film
finalement les parents les votes essai
de sébastien roques sens un peu comme ça
alors ce qui est extraordinaire dans ce
film c'est que les parents ils sont
morts sans être mort ils sont enfouis
sous un glacier dans les alpes
alors c'est à dire qu'ils existent
encore c'est un peu comme toi voilà
c'est un peu comme quand on disparaît en
mer ouais c'est à dire on aime on peut
pas faire de deuil puisque toute façon
les les corps on les a jamais vues donc
ils sont enfouis dans un glacier sont
pas vraiment mort mais comme ils sont
dans la glace quelque part il reste
jeune si c'est beau comme comme image
regardez ce que tu nous racontes là
magnéto sur la carte vermeil tu fermes
ta gueule
comment êtes-vous 10 août et enfin
aujourd'hui je suis pas je te dit de
fermer ta bouche
non c'est rien c'est pas la peine de
mort maintenant j'essaie un casse toi
allez dégagez automaticité envers de
normal c'est l'âge ya des appareils
papao il a de l'humour le petit merdeux
toshiba toi ça suffit tu en as eu plein
temps sur un ne cherche pas de mariage à
ce que tu as dit des galas les caisses
qui arrivait jamais suspense ils vont se
battre ses charmes
ouais ouais mais tu en a pas mais
renoncer pendant leur garde chine
inquiète pas les mecs c'est toujours
comme ça ils pensent ferman ne serait
pas duré de mahler mon par quelque chose
les os ça suffit maintenant tu es
content voilà on fait chier tous les
duels on va beaucoup mieux tous les
extrémistes sortie le 19 avril enfin
c'est un premier pas mal je dis je dirai
la vérité il ya sébastien roch dans le
film sébastien rogues konaté cricri
d'amour écrits d'amour justement mais
qui fait cri d'amour qui finalement est
à c'est assez bien mais c'est qui fait
des courts métrages heavy rain mais ça
va être cool là on est entre copains
regarder à
je vais faire ça à faire c'est cool tu
veux le faire raoul brûlât pétards
la porte c'est son surnom d'ailleurs
raul en paix tu as tu marques tu vas
voir qui c'est raoul bien alors vous les
rapports vous avez avec vos parents
c'est un peu quand même ce type de
rapport ne s'était pas trop mai 68
ouais non beaux-parents wave 1 mes
parents ouais enfin votre père était pas
souvent même nom il n'était pas là
souvent mais n'était pas trop mais soyez
il n'avait pas conscience politique
il s'en foutait un peu quand même et
d'ailleurs heureusement mais vous dites
quand vous faites des gta vous vous
dites aujourd'hui ma tête aujourd'hui
m'appelle beaucoup en parlant votre père
dit il m'appelle beaucoup pour rattraper
les années oui je sois là pour rattraper
mais c'est vrai quand on s'appelle
souvent peut-être on n'a rien à se dire
mais bon on s'appelle tout le temps
ouais et donc au bar on se demande sans
moi machin donc non on n'a pas une
conversation plus d'affinités avec votre
mère web avec ma mère on s'appelle 14
fois donc on perd ça fait quand on
s'appelle quatre fois par jour vous
dites c'est la fusion avec ma mère c'est
mon double si vous n'arrivez pas à
décrocher de votre mère c'est ça non
mais j'ai pas envie en fait parce que
c'est une personne avec l'âge passant à
l'escouade j'ai 26 ans non mais en même
temps quand c'est quelqu'un qui les
intéresse pas vraiment pourquoi
alors quand vous étiez enfant vous
habitez à bougival en 76 quand les
valseuses sont sortis ce n'était pas
évident à l'école le matin quand vous
arriviez on vous regardez un peu de
traviole quoi ouais bah oui c'est à dire
que c'était quand même très très
bourgeois et les gens disaient
non non il parle pas la façon dont je
parlais jamais jeu dès qu'on me
demandait quoi que ce soit c'était rouge
et muette donc forcément on n'a pas trop
envie de me parler mais de toute façon
personne mais parce que mon père était
considéré comme c'était facile plus est
un grand film me dire c'est plus
choquant est politiquement hyper
incorrect et donc moi je me rendais bien
compte quand même sous les dehors
d'abrutis je sentais bien qu'il y avait
un truc qui cloche et les copines elle
vous disaient mes parents veulent pas
trop que je te vois là ouais ouais on
était un peu perdu vous dites nous dit
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de franchise
vous dit si j'avais une copine
protestante je devenais protestante je
voulais protestante
j'avais une copine juive je voulais lui
même parce que moi j'ai pas été enfin
mes parents moi jamais mieux au
catéchisme ne sont jamais rien fait pour
mot mon devenir spirituelle non mais
qu'est ce que je vous dis à 8 ans j'ai
commencé à me poser des question j'ai
dit mais où il est dieu sait quoi
donc j'ai commencé à copier tout le
monde n'a pas répondu jamais non et
pareil quand c'était philo que je fais
des études de philo quoi dit abrutis et
tout mais ça fait quand même des études
assez oui vous savez quoi oui j'ai fait
cinq ans j'ai redoublé deux fois comme
c'est beaucoup quand même bien oui
j'aimais beaucoup aussi
donc vous dites d'ailleurs quand je
lisais heideger je suis d'accord avec
heidegger dans le lendemain je disais
kierkegaard
j'étais d'accord et kierkegaard non mais
c'est vrai ben oui parce que je fusionne
moi j'y peux rien quand un mec il a une
argumentation
voilà obligés de fusionner on est obligé
d'être d'accord histoires comme ça qui
est affreuse mais la paix n'a rien à
voir avec ce qu'elle raconte est allé un
peu hard on est un peu tard je peux le
raconter c'est un type qui va chez le
toubib et que dis je comprends pas je
mange des petits pois je chie les petits
pois je mange des haricots je chie des
haricots
je mange du riz je chie du rythme alors
oui le tweet du bas à bouffer de la
merde
et vous croyez pas si bien dit à laurent
ruquier par exemple julie chez elle
commence à manger des cônes elle va
manger pendant 15 jours 1 et oui ils
vont vers 18h20 tchador elle a des sites
comme ça les défusions c'est ça c'est
bien assez bien le moins en verve 18 19
ans vous commencé à sortir tous les
soirs sans commencer vous ai fait un peu
la bringue la cwa bougival banon à paris
oui j'avais pas de boîte à bout gignac
rassurez moi vous dites j'ai fait le
tour des excès puis alors vous aimez pas
les vacances voient maintenant mais
franchement sheeran
non j'ai jamais mais même à 13 ce n'est
pas ce que vous êtes tellement intense
que les vacances nous exaspère quoi
l'idée qu'on est visée directe je peux
pas à vous culpabiliser pendant les
vacances je fais pas ce sens je suis
allergique à tout la mer le soleil je
déteste le palmier ça me dépayse pas je
veux dire le calme et ne dépayse pas
quand même c'est rien ça m'angoisse
encore plus sûre qu'est ce qu'on fait là
non si je vous dit que vous êtes un peu
grunge et ben non vous n'êtes pas grunge
s'est pas fait non mais je me sens pas
du tout grand danger que vous sentez
quoi sic
ah oui c'est vrai la nuit vous écoutez
de l'opéra mais le jour tout le temps
arrêt
à midi tout le temps c'est une drogue
vous êtes par exemple plutôt galets en
vacances à la mer c'est vrai que dans
des monastères chez les jésuites j
allais way j'allais chez jésuites pour
faire mes examens j'ai plus d'examens
mais peut-être que je vais me réinscrire
parce que quand même besoin d'un psy
chez les jésuites mais aux examens donc
chez les jésuites aussi et non parce
qu'il faut un suivi quand même il sent
quelque chose il faut que quelque chose
se passe
manquer de repères nous avons une façon
non non non non c'est parce que j'en ai
plein des repères mais je trouve que
c'est
j'ai pas envie d'avoir trop de repères
il faut qu'ils aient plusieurs choses
qui se contredit je trouve que c'est
bien plus déstabilisant en avoir
plusieurs choses qui se contredisent par
exemple vous n'êtes pas baptisé 1 mais
vous avez vous avez voulu à un moment
vous avait sérieusement envisagé de
devenir religieuse ouais non mais moi
j'aime j'aime le contact des gens vont à
la fois
ouais si vous voulez moi je ne l'est pas
pas encore peut-être mais j'aimerais
l'avoir et je trouve ça magnifique
dévoilé on vous dit que vous êtes quoi
c'est très à la mode d'être bouddhistes
en ce moment surtout le cinéma dans les
touristes vous dites je prends je suis
attiré par des religions qui sont plus
sanctionnant tu des religions où tout
est interdit
on se rejoint bien ce que j'ai tout à
l'heure et génération qui manque de
points d'attaché tu vois ses besoins de
son q7 vous avez été élevé avec trop de
liberté mais je préfère la psychanalyse
le bistrot mais c'était est élevé avec
trop de liberté et aujourd'hui vous
manquez de contraintes et finalement on
fait les choses bien quand on à
l'intérêt de conserver la censure ah oui
ça aide
ouais des choses contre lesquelles se
rebeller c'est vraiment bah oui enfin
c'est un moteur un molière la faune
surtout ça très mystique comme émissions
ont finalement dit pas que des conneries
ça je vois ça bien sûr si on tient bien
on peut aller jusqu'à la messe de marée
basse
toute façon je tiens à dire que vous ne
faites aucun reproche à vos parents
parce que de toute façon les parents
quoi qu'ils fassent ils en prennent
toujours plein la gueule toute façon
quand ils sont quand ils sont durs on
leur reproche des durées quand ils sont
laxistes on leur reproche d'être laxiste
donc toute façon vous géré par an c'est
quand même assez sacerdotale votre façon
c'est toujours engueuler toujours oui
donc si les parents disent à leurs
enfants que tu sais que je me suis
sacrifié pour toi les enfants disent bah
écoutes je n'ai jamais demandé moi c'est
terrible vous faites les canaliser la un
mois ouais ouais c'est vrai que c'est
bien ça je ne crois rien j'y suis j'agis
ça nous plaît franchement eux n'ont pas
tous les jours franchement ça me plaît
pas ouais mais je me dis il faut y aller
j'ai commencé je continue et une
discipline plein c'est une aventure
oui c'est un truc aventure on se dit
qu'est ce qu'il va y avoir au bout rien
peut-être quelque chose on ne sait pas
au top je vous disais que vous êtes chez
grin je voulais passer un peu nos futurs
quand même mais pas du tout
vous avez le désir j'avais le désir
d'être et un désir des trajets
finalement passé quand vous soulevez dit
penser que les gens âgés en plus de
sagesse plus de distance sur les
chaudières 26 ans je me sens comme si
j'avais 76 ouais donc j'imagine qu'elle
76 tonnes je serai une jeunesse et il ya
ces ouais bah oui j'aurais envie d'être
jeune donc bah oui c'est ce qui arriva
balladur lorsqu'il veut s'émanciper à 70
ans voilà c'est un second cité moi je
pense que 76 ans
il faudra que ça suive si je suis là
dieu merci en tout cas maintenant je
vous faire quand vous êtes une famille
de cinéma les 2 par dieu a clairement
xavier perramond que ça saoule tout le
monde parce que vers vous et c'est un
honnête dernière roue du carrosse pense
pas que les gens vous donnent des
premiers rôles dans les films juste pour
faire plaisir à votre perte
non loin de là mais en même temps on se
dit bon bah y'a quand même un air de
famille enfin je veux dire avec mon
frère tu mets les cheveux longs c'est
moi c'est vrai un dans l'affairé
alors justement julie depardieu comme
famille cinéma je vous fais un intel ou
cinéma et vous ne bougez pas pendant le
jingle jeudi soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est des questions qui sont faites à
partir de titres de films
quand vous pensez à gérard depardieu est
ce que vous pensez à mon père ce héros
et non mon père c'est zéro pour résumer
votre lit non c'est pas vrai pour le
pour résumer votre vie est ce que vous
pensez fardeau mon père se farde pour
résumer votre vie est ce que vous pensez
à l'itinéraire d'un enfant gâté
moi oui
ben non oui et non roland dubillard oui
mais non oui mais non
la folie des grandeurs si vous êtes
arrivé est ce que votre devis c'est
l'important c'est d'aimer pas dire oui
il faut pas dire oui vrai que les hommes
préfèrent les blondes
j'ose espérer vous préférez les maris
les femmes les amants les amants vous
dire que ni le diable au corps vous
attend déjà surnommé julie pot de colle
ouais je me cramponne et si votre jules
vous disais nous ne vieillirons pas
ensemble
je suis d'accord l'invité que je vais
accueillir maintenant et écrivain et
cinéaste
quand il fait des bouquins il en vend
des millions d'exemplaires et quand il
fait des films il ya des millions de
téléspectateurs
c'est alexandre jardin c'est tout
il y avait du ko
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir tout le monde connaît
alexandre jardin quand même
julie vous connaissez tous le monde où
tout le monde le connaît avec son jardin
son premier bouquin son premier bouquin
justement c'était bille en tête en 1986
l'histoire d'un jeune homme de 16 ans
qui séduit une amie milliardaire de son
père et on a cru d'ailleurs c'est
tellement bien
tout le monde a cru que c'était votre
père qui l'avait écrit pascal jardin on
a cru que c'était françoise verny votre
éditrice qu'il avait écrit et finalement
c'était vous ce que je n'ai écrit
d'autres depuis plus beau frère
malheureusement n'est plus là et
françoise verny n'est plus en état
donc trois cent mille exemplaires et
prix du premier roman pour un premier
roman donc bravo déjà très beau début
alors je les fais pas tous mais je cite
les plus connus à prilly le zèbre en
vous avez été le plus jeune lauréat du
prix femina un million d'exemplaires
traduits dans six pays et un film fait
par jean poiret enfants 1990 neuf cent
mille exemplaires
c'est ce pays-là ce coup ci c'est plus 6
et 16 le zubial en 97 qui consacrait à
votre père justement qui votent
véritable entrée en littérature c'est
dire qu'il critique du foie comme un
petit peu besoin le museau sur vos
bouquins subias je crois qu'il ya pas eu
de discussion tout le monde a reconnu un
vrai talent d'auteur voilà pour les
livres on passe au film alors il eut
fanfan 93 donc avec sophie marceau et
vincent perez 1 million de spectateurs
hier il ya un truc qui rassure quand
même c'est quand 96 il rien l'échec
ça fait plaisir et c'est à dire d'un
seul coup ça vous ramène dans la
normalité on va vous êtes là un être
humain comme les autres et vous trompez
donc ça s'appelait oui en 96 et c'est un
échec
et aujourd'hui bas
alors a commencé avec le livre
autobiographie d'un amour voilà donc
chez gallimard autobiographie d'un amour
là c'est toujours tous les héros
s'appelle alexandra c'est à dire assez
de la mégalomanie de l'ironie c'est quoi
non c'est pendant très longtemps je n'ai
pas trop aimé ma vie et je me ferai le
luxe avec un stylo de mener une vie
acceptable et d'écrire sur des
personnages que je trouvais beaucoup
mieux que moi c'est un peu fini
bon donc mais ils vont quand même ça
plaît toujours alexandre les héros parce
que dans votre sim on va reparler après
il s'appelle encore avec c'est
probablement d'ailleurs le dernier
alexandre que je crains c'est la fin d
alexandre d'accord alors dans ce dans ce
bouquin autobiographique d'un amour donc
c'est le haïk sons du moment du livre
qui découvre que sa femme se sent un peu
seul dans son mariage il disparaît il
disparaît la laisse quand même avec les
avec les gosses c'est surtout un type
qui découvre la vérité de sa femme un
joueur qui tombe un jour sur le cahier
intime de sa femme et qui découvre avec
qui il vit et la dernière fois que ça
vous est arrivé vous va vous avez pris
comment moi j'ai divorcé une fois déjà
et c'est bien en gros ils découvrent une
catastrophe
il découvre que c'est trop tard et il
disparaît et deux ans après son frère
jumeau qui a un qui revient et son frère
jumeau il est très inspirée de l'oeuvre
d'un psychiatre américain qui me
passionne voilà qui s'appelle milton
erickson qu'est-ce-qui direction' c'est
quoi son message c'est quelqu'un qui a
une approche complètement stratégiques
c'est-à-dire qu'elle lorsqu'il s'adresse
à quelqu'un
tout ce qu'il fait va être destiné à le
manipuler pour arriver à le faire
changer à son insu et quand je dis à son
insu c'est quelqu'un qui ne qui ne
parlent jamais directement par exemple
si s'il veut faire un compliment une
femme il ne va pas dire vous êtes jolie
il va dire je vous trouve désirable et
lorsque je vous trouve dès lors ce que
je trouve une femme désirable
ça me donne soif il va se mettre à boire
un verre d'eau comme ça c'est pour toi
une vieille copine c'est vraiment idiot
mais c'est vrai
elle était parmi les sectateurs les
thuriféraires de l'est vraiment défendre
linder en france avant ce grand nom bien
avant tout le monde bat avant recchi
avoriaz 9 pour la première fois que j'ai
vu en concert on était dans une toute
petite salle au sentier des halles
il y avait plus de monde sur la scène
que drass et c'est vrai le club des amis
de lynda lemay ce soir bon alors
ericsson et donc il va dire par exemple
à une femme
lorsque je trouve une femme désirable ça
me donne soif il va boire un verre d'eau
ouais si le lendemain il sort points
devant la fille qui lui dit rien mais
qu'il la regarde en coin qui boit un
verre d'eau bien évidemment comprendre
c'est à dire que c'est tout ce sont
c'est toute une stratégie indirecte peut
pas dire que c'est pas mal quand je
m'emmerde pendant une émission dans la
suite de l'émission chaque fois qu'il ya
un plan sur lui comme ça voilà il aura
une action est directionnelle
c'est génial et j'ai senti ses lentilles
fred quand on dit c'est l'anti freud ce
qui le passionne ce n'est pas pourquoi
les gens vont mal mais comment ils vont
pouvoir changer
ouais et ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
mettre en place des stratégies pour
faire changer et c'est ce que fait le
héros de ce livre
donc ça c'est autobiographie nalement ce
besoin est vendu combien ces énormes
dont vous êtes toujours dans les 200 à
250 milles zoom zoom mon garçon 250 me
dupeux zoomer bien et maintenant on
passe passe au film parce que jardin
quand il vient c'est pas pour rien si la
tête bien compile c'est la cantine
jardin accompli alors on passe donc le
prof
d'après un roman à vous qui s'appelle le
petit sauvage qui sortent donc ça sort
le 12 avril avec jean hugues anglade
yvan attal hélène de fougerolles
alors ces deux grands propre comme on
aurait aimé en avoir à l'école chacun
incarne unity je me trompe pas chacun
incarne une partie de nous-mêmes une
facette de nous mêmes c'est à dire les
envies et les peurs sûr que tous ses
envies et tous des peurs et il y en a un
qui essaye de faire en sorte que qu'une
génération entière des élèves d'un lycée
sortent avec un avec un bac qui signifie
qu'ils vont avoir une véritable capacité
à rester vivants c'est à dire une
capacité à n'être qu'un changement est
et c'est vrai que quand on était gamins
on sait bien qu'entre 6 ans et 6 ans et
demi et 7 ans ont changé et lorsqu'on
commence à entrer dans le monde adulte
c'est le grand coup de frein et tout à
coup
qu'est-ce que vous êtes devenu en trois
semaines depuis trois semaines c'est pas
sûr que vous alliez continuer à évoluer
ouais alors que trois semaines alors que
alors alors alors que vos gamins ça
serait on aurait tous bu reau trois
semaines alors que alors que nos gamins
en trois semaines ils ont continué et
bien c'est exactement ce qu anglade
essayent de faire avec ses élèves
ils essayent de fait d'en faire des
êtres qui ne seront qu'un changement
c'est à dire des êtres vivants puisque
ce qui est vivant c'est ce qui change
c'est ce qui se métamorphose et on a
tourné ce film avec l' envie qu'on sorte
de la salle avec le désir d'entrer dans
cette dimension de la vie
non madame
enfin la pression collective 87% des
sujets interrogés en viennent à douter
de leur propre perception
alors voilà gardez vos vérités ou 18 ans
je ne vous souhaite pas ma quarantaine
vraiment pas un ni ses nouveaux profs
d'ailleurs il ne faut hélas pas être aux
particuliers pour qu'un système vous
reconnaissent les universités les
entreprises cherchent un profil type est
pas un caractère trop marquée autrement
dit je lis votre singularité vous pouvez
la garder mon conseil pour réussir soyez
grise terne
vous connaissez votre problème se trouve
il je crois malheureusement que vous
preniez pourtant choix je suis aux gens
comme lui je me déteste
[ __ ] tu puisses pas un bordel c'est
moi qui suis pas récupérable je suis de
des commentaires serré tout sec égoïste
je la sentais ta connerie mais je ne la
voyais pas arriver suisse a sans trop
aller déguster la pièce pour que j'y
crois tu t'habilles en ado qui déménage
alors qu'ici on s'embrasse non je crois
pas là avec toi c'est toujours irréel
j'ai l'impression de rêver
kan a reconnu que si j'étais à votre
place je serais très séduit par ce
langage
je vous comprends bien sûr que je vous
comprends parce que je les ai eus vo 18
ans je ne veux plus vous utilisez les
stéréotypes et des mots qui sont pas
tous je crois pas qu'ils songent à ses
cours mais comme ça franchement un
regard leurs parents regardent leurs
parents des ados aux bêtises en moi je
peux pas me permettre de tout contesté
de tout brûler en joie je dois d'avoir
passé mon bac
voulez vous appreniez ici et mais comme
si vous l'aviez jamais été blessé ni
orthez donc c'est comme si personne et
vous regardez à travailler comme si vous
n'avez même pas besoin et surtout je ne
dis rien plutôt que je sais voilà c'est
ça l'idée le programme ça s'appelle le
prof
c'est tiré du petit sauvage alexandre
jardin s'est réalisée par exemple jardin
il ya jean hugues anglade qui est
séduisant mais alors top craquons quoi
je veux dire ah oui c'est fait pour
citer une gonzesse mois jean hugues
anglade vous pouvez pas qu'il aille
sourit il est beau et même attal souris
dans votre film ce comme extraordinaire
parce que yvan attal
j'avais vu sourire de ma vie il envoie
souris deux fois dit la même chose de
louche non moi sourit alors tout le
monde est boosté enfin les deux sont
boostés par hélène de fougerolles que je
crois pour qu'elle tourne pas plus est
hélène de fougerolles
mais honnêtement lorsqu'elle est rentrée
dans mon bureau je me suis dit je sais
mais pourquoi je su pourquoi elle n'a
pas fait déjà 30 films bah oui c'est
bizarre c'est l'alcool samsonite voilà
ça me semble évident que ça va être
elle tournait beineix là ouais elle
commence a repris le même casting
puisque il a repris anglade et hélène de
fougerolles et alors parce que je trouve
dissiper la justice est plutôt du côté
anglade que du côté atteint c'est pas ça
c'est qu'il ya julie depardieu très
justement j'ai cru que ces samy naceri
je me suis dit c'est pas possible
c'est elle a commencé à me caresser à
bajus livré courant
je me suis dit c'est bizarre qu'est ce
qui se passe là c'est sami qu'il faut
caresser
mais enfin mais bon je veux bien que
c'était des caresses de m'échanger place
changer immédiatement de place ça va
comme ça ce sera juste un jury toi vous
caresser il contacte alors lorsqu'on
voit non vous faites vos affaires entre
eux et nous avons fait nos affaires
serge tu laisses une caméra sûr comme ça
on verra ce qui sait ce qui s'est passé
tu laisses une caméra diverger sur
recherche s'il te plaît donc il ya votre
intérêt alexandre iata gré à brel
exactement le genre de comportement que
j'ai envie que mon film déclenché cela
j'ai envie qu'on sorte des salles avec
des encours gérés avec son jardin si
votre fils aîné laurent ruquier à
s'intéresser et voire plus si affinités
julie depardieu
je pense qu'il aura vraiment servi à
quelques se satisfaire pour journée
formidable a laissé et voilà d'abord
c'est rare une pauvresse fringué comme
ça je veux dire c'est voilà une émission
des phrases ça te dire là vraiment c'est
génial si l'émission qui fera plaisir à
tamerlan
on ne dit pas gonzesses prennent une
forme une femme s mais voilà avec témoin
la comptine attachant
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors ce qu'on voit dans votre
film s'en foutent vous êtes complètement
jardini cela là vous êtes un vrai jardin
il se comporte comme enghelab dans
l'oeuf exactement dans ce qu'on voit
dans ce film c'est votre votre intérêt
pour l'éducation nationale quand vous ai
fait sciences po
ces patients le doigt dans le nez vous
avez fait sciences po vous vous vouliez
en fait vous occupez de réforme de
l'éducation nationale c'est pas un truc
récentes sur un film qui par l'éducation
nationale au delà de données en question
ça parle de l'éducation d'ailleurs je
lance un appel à jack lang
si vous avez besoin d'un conseiller jack
faut pas faire ça il va il va débarquer
c'est vrai vous étiez vraiment face à
l'ecofin l'école à sciences po vous
étiez intéressé par les problèmes
d'éducation nationale oui bah oui parce
que parce que les vrais questions
politiques m'intéresse voilà ce devait
être un homme de gouvernement en fait
non denses bêta non ce qui me faisait
rêver
et ce qui me fait toujours rêver c'est
c'est de faire en sorte de vivre dans
une société génial et c'est vrai que
pour moi
le fait de faire un film sur le monde de
l'éducation nationale avec le prof c'est
ça va dans la même logique voulait
changer la société
oui et c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire en ce moment mais une association
brière qui prouve que c'est pas du
pipeau qui s'appelle lire et faire lire
il ya déjà 100 écrivains qui sont mêlé à
ça c'est quoi le but de cette assoc
c'est très simple c'est de faire en
sorte qu'ils plus un gamin qui entrent
en sixième en france sans savoir lire et
comment en transmettant par le plaisir
y a pas d'autre solution que de
transmettre le plaisir et on a trouvé
une solution très simple qui est
d'étendre à tous pays
une initiative qui a fonctionné à brest
pendant quinze ans ça consiste à faire
venir les retraités dans les écoles
primaires ça oui c'est ça oui c'est moi
j'ai entendu parler de ça je sais pas
que c'était sa part dit non et alors on
a déjà douze départements qui ont
démarré après pâques on en aura 30 et on
aura la grosse majorité des départements
français qui vont démarrer à la rentrée
et on quelle est sa place pour les
jeunes dans les écoles si en plus on y
met les vieux et simplement je profite
d'être là pour dire que si vous s'il ya
des instits qui nous regardent le des
directeurs d'école il faut qu'ils
appellent et s'il ya des retraités qui
veulent faire ça dans leur commune ou
dans leur quartier il ya un numéro de
téléphone
voici un numéro de claude allègre qui va
s'afficher non c'est le 0 825 832 833
ils sont tous pareils 832 800 de la
gigue la télévision et finalement si on
veut résumer un peu simplement c'est que
vous êtes vraiment à mi chemin entre
votre grand père qui était proche de
l'êta était proche du pouvoir avec
toutes ces idées là est proche de votre
père qui se préoccupaient plutôt des
femmes soit vous êtes à un parfait mix
entre votre père et votre grand père
quoi suis je suis une sorte d'hybride
extraordinaire la famille de jardin mais
comme ils sont tous écrivains chaque
enfant écrit sur le
sur son père donc votre grand votre père
a écrit pascal jardin a écrit sur son
père donc un formidable la guerre à 9
ans la guerre à 9,1 et le nain jaune 1
donc votre père a écrit pascal jardin
écrit sur son père jean jardin et vous
alexandre jardin vous avez écrit un
livre le zubial sur votre père pascal
jardin donc chacun écrit comme ça votre
fils cuira faisait des enfants trois
filles et un garçon maintenant 33 mais
qu ils s'appellent que ryanair qui va
écrire sur loire c'est sûr j'espère pas
parce que jouer
dites moi alors votre grand père était
directeur du cabinet de pierre laval à
vichy il n'a pas une mauvaise image
jeudi rebond papon ça a été la ruée
ça a été la lie il n'y a pas eu que lui
d'ailleurs mais votre grand père il
passe un peu à la ce dans tout ça
pourquoi parce qu'il avait joué le
double jeu pendant la guerre parce qu'il
avait pris soin de sauver des juifs
parce que les gens de l'ombre dont
toujours des vies un peu plus compliqué
ouais et que la réalité des mais moi ça
me pose quand même un très gros problème
ouais malgré ça ça vous embête d'en
parler non non c'est pas ça
non ça me pose un problème dans la vie
oui problèmes dans la vie ouais qu'est
ce qu'il ya ben voilà alors j'ai dit
c'est moi qui prends c'est comme à
l'école ya turin coupable voilà la voilà
le camp c'est sûr ce sont les mêmes que
cinq ans c'est pareil quand j'étais
gamin vous lui faites en effet julie
extraordinaire c'est pour ma foi je vois
comme ça et moi je fais pas d'effets
manu facile alors moi je vous caresse le
coude vous avez votre col de veste et
tous en dessous là et c'est un premier
siège
alors votre père romancier scénariste or
le nombre de films qu'il a fait même pas
le temps de les citer il a fait part mme
ida des scénarii où les dialogues parmi
les plus grands films français votent
une centaine de films et 70 46 ans
certaines années il a dû écrire jusqu'à
17 films il vivait une vie assez
particulière il est mort quand vous
aviez 15 ans et vous dites il n'est pas
vraiment mort du cancer
il est mort d'avoir vécu toujours à
l'extrême on peut pas impunément et mais
sans femmes faire sans fil perdre 100
millions et roulait toujours à cent à
l'heure
si une vie ça vous fait fantasmer vous à
l'homme pressé ce m'a toujours fait
fantasmer moi ben effectivement il a
vécu comme ça c'est à dire que chaque
seconde a été d'une intensité
exceptionnelle
moi j'ai vécu 15 ans il est mort lorsque
j'avais 15 ans et chaque seconde a été a
été brûlée avec une obsession c'était
d'essayer aussi de me transmettre une
certaine idée de l'amour et c'est vrai
que là la première fois que j'ai ramené
une fille à la maison il m'a dit il m'a
vu en larmes parce que elle est repartie
en train pour la yougoslavie et il m'a
dit écoute mon chéri on saute dans
l'avion c'est ça le train on arrive en
yougoslavie avant que le train arrive
demain matin tu seras sur le quai elle
te trouver là tu deviens inoubliable
ouais et les filles se souviendront de
toi dans sa famille pendant quinze
génération on l'a sacrée personnes dans
la foulée effet on l'a fait on a fait on
a rattrapé le train dans la nuit
on est arrivé à lubjana et j'étais sur
le quai lui était planqué
derrière un journal un peu plus loin et
la fille moi j'avais 13 ans elle en
avait 18
elle a sauté du train il a sauté dans
les bras d'un type qui en avait je me
suis planqué derrière le poteau je suis
devenu tout gris on s'est regardés avec
mon père est d'abaisser le journal en
est reparti je rame et c'est un
personnage je vais pas raconter le
zubial parce que finalement tout le
monde peut acheter
faut lire le bouquin chaque année ces
femmes et ces maîtresses se retrouve à
sainte-clotilde quand même
extraordinaire quand il s'adonne votre
fantasme pas votre mort pendant 15 ans
elle sort tout il y avait quand il quand
il roulait ma femme est là à le croire
quand il roulait sur la route il prenait
toujours le panneaux autres directions
il envoyait sa crosse par jour à une
prostituée d'hôtel qui était son
directeur littéraire et si l'exception
directeur littéraire est alors pire que
tout il mettait des phrases du général
de gaulle parce qu'il a écrit les
dialogues d'angélique il mettait des
phrases du général de gaulle dans dans
la dans la bouche d'angélique enfin
c'est vraiment un type
moi ça m'a donné mais je l'avais lu le
bouquin concessionnaire m'a donné envie
de le relire un homme libre un homme
librement alors vous dites à la fin du
bouquin d'ailleurs ce sera la dernière
phrase ta mort enfin cessé de nous
séparer
alors on va faire un petit anti portrait
chinois ne bouge pas julie pendant le
giguère
[Applaudissements]
ce qui démarre pando pipi c'est vrai oui
malaisie est une émission libre ici vous
savez ya pas de problème à les faire des
pires mois comme ça on sera tous combien
de temps j'allais bien que c'était pas
maquiller sa vie modeste avec ça bien
alors attention se concentre j'espère
que julie depardieu n'étant plus là
elles sont illégales et demi serait un
petit peu plus concentré mon cher vu qui
est donc vous connaissez le portrait
chinois si j'étais vous voulez vous ne
répondez pas voulu répondre jardin si
j'étais une fleur je serai mieux
autistes ça c'est l'anti portrait
chinois
donc évidemment c'est pas de fleurs dont
je vais vous parler si vous étiez un
défaut je serais un homme si vous étiez
une injure
si j'étais une injure je serai une
ben il y à un cas d'injures
extraordinaire qui est devenu un mot
positif des [ __ ] oui oui c'est vrai
c'est que les [ __ ] aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui c'est magnifique c'est bien
sûr c'est qu'ils se donnent du mal pour
faire partie des [ __ ] c'est comme
l'académie française pour faire partie
des [ __ ] c'est un long et oui les
nageurs qui me va car elle karen mulder
a mis des années pour être accepté par
les [ __ ] être acceptée par les
[ __ ] aujourd'hui c'est l'académie
française il faut rendre des visites
si vous étiez un collabo jeu non qua non
non j'ai pas envie d'être un collabo si
vous étiez une maladie si j'étais une
maladie je serai je serai une maladie
très grave
producteur de cinéma c'est à dire ces
fous furieux qui à un moment donné paris
sur les rêves des autres déjà parier sur
les siens c'est déjà des membres way sur
ceux des autres
si vous étiez un accident bain plutôt un
coup de foudre voilà vous étiez une
perversion
les seules vraies pervers qui nous
plaisent je pense à ces gens très
manipulateur je pense à talleyrand ou où
ces hommes politiques féroce terribles
qui ont été des pervers la perversion me
va lorsqu'elle va pour défendre
l'intérêt général
la raison d'état et le sens de l'intérêt
général
si vous étiez une guerre une guerre
scolaire un diktat via une guerre
scolaire un dictateur il ya un dictateur
si j'étais un dictateur jeu
charlie chaplin ou ou un autre encore
plus inoffensif jacques chirac c'était à
coup ci c'est parce que le chirac en
dictateur ils seront pas prêts mais geof
si vous étiez un vice je sais pas c'est
si j'étais un vie serait je crois que je
serai thierry ardisson or parce que
faire un anti portrait comme ça ouais
s'adressant à moi ouais c'est pervers
mais ça marche c'est un petit portrait
chinois il hommage très bien que les
écrivains
j'ai remarqué sur ça quand j'ai des
écrivains je leur fais ça parce que si
vous étiez une arme une arme un clitoris
est ce que ses larmes quand même qu'ils
ses larmes se crashe donc lui fait la
loi sur la terre ouais voilà un clitoris
nord d'après lui oui ah ça fait la loi
sur la terre si vous étiez un supplice
monsieur tu normes parce que quand on
peu pressé sur la détente
[Applaudissements]
il manquait une petite justification un
supplice un supplice
un livret supplice ces scellés
les rêves d'enfants qu'on n'arrive pas à
quitter quoi ces trucs qui nous lâchent
pas une panne il fane une panne une
panne je dirais le le bug de l'an 2000
on l'est pour que moi il y en a eu un
ouais mais cette fois qu'il est réussie
que si vous étiez un [ __ ] bref je
pensais pas vous parce qu'on l'a déjà
répondu 500 fois non non non si j'étais
un sale ça me ferait des vacances parce
que honnêtement ça doit être jouissif
parfois je me suis dit mais qu'est ce
que ça fait de se lâcher complètement
parce que là on est tous traversé quand
même par des instincts un peu bas et
puis quand même on retient qui est
honnêtement je me suis jamais vraiment
lâché pour me comporter en france l eau
il devait y voit une forme de jouissance
l'aide sûrement je vous étiez un poison
l'illettrisme un assassin c'est
peut-être le pire des poisons vous étiez
un assassin je serai
je crois que je serais si j'étais un
assassin je crois que je serai
une erreur judiciaire je crois je l'aï
nation si vous étiez une torture si
j'étais une torture je serai je serai
hélène de fougerolles
je rendrai fous les hommes et je me
donnerai pas si vous étiez une mort si
j'étais une marge je crois que je serai
une mort choisie mais mais comme j'ai
l'intention de mourir très vieux pas
comme mon père il fasse un peu de temps
pour terminer la réponse très bien merci
j'accueille maintenant le goal du psg
alias monsieur simeone 2015 à grande
dominique casagrande bonsoir vous
connaissez tous le monde julie depardieu
laurent ok j'ai déjà pu la cote elle
veut changer de place j aurais pu me
dire qu'il était bon c'est sympa je te
remercie samy naceri eric raoult et
lynda lemay la nouvelle coqueluche de
paris est vexant de jardin qui comme
chaque année nous fessons millions
d'exemplaires de livres 100 millions de
téléspectateurs de philippe laureau
mesure 1 m 89 peser 82 kg pas mal
alors samedi dernier le psg s'est
qualifié pour sa troisième finale de la
coupe de la ligue en éliminant bastia 4
à 2,1 alors le psg sera opposé le 22
avril au fc gueugnon au stade de france
c'est quand même bizarre que des clubs
comme gueugnon mais ça me surprend
toujours il ya eu quelques années il
gagne on commet des petits clubs comme
ça il va se retrouver face à des grands
clubs comme le psg
ces deux-là quoi ça veut dire que tous
les bons joueurs sont à l'étranger ou
pas
pour résumer c'est vrai que c'est ça
c'est que trader sur l'étranger le
niveau perdu le championnat français est
en train de baisser
bah oui ah bah non il faudrait peut-être
ça nous quitter c'est peut-être pas les
petits qui sont plus forts c'est
peut-être les grands qui sont plus
mauvais ouais donc c'est ça l'histoire
c'est peut-être sa part ainsi que c'est
des compétitions celle là qui se joue
sur un match ou à des matches aller
retour donc c'est pas comme un
championnat
oui le psg joue pas contre gueugnon
contre khaled en championnat de france
c'est sur un match que ces jeunes à ces
équipes-là joue tout sur un match
j'imagine les petites équipes
oui mais ça fait longtemps que c'est
comme ça donc c'est pas nouveau c'est ce
qui est nouveau c'est qu'ils arrivent au
bout maintenant et qui sont présents
dans une demi finale et une finale en
coupe de la ligue le 22 avril au stade
de france pourrait vous faire battre par
gueugnon n'est sûr je pense pas mais tu
répètes ce que tu as dit avec antoine et
sa famille si toi je dis des conneries
à l'époque le psg
1 m 89 à l'époque lé psg permet tout le
temps donc je sais que c'était une
passoire et puis comme sa nana elle
présentait la météo toutes les filles
qui part de météo sa femme pardon c'est
peut-être pas votre femme encore à
l'époque d'ailleurs mais mais en tout
cas votre fiancée j'ai dit oui c'était
une gourde qui épousa une passoire
c'était méchant je vais faire comme eric
raoult et je fais mon mea culpa et je
regrette et ça sera pas dans mon best of
à la fin mais voilà
c'était pour faire un mot ça aurait pu
être n'importe quel goût avait chaussé
et la passion des échanges et et
n'importe quel gardien de but parce
qu'en fait je ne vais jamais vu jouer et
sans essayer de ne pas que c'est une
passoire et serait pas exactement il
serait peut être n'importe quelle fille
qui présente la météo mais c'est pas une
passoire
c'est un gardien c'est un très bon garde
les problèmes avec l'ama mais on va y
venir gibeau là bas tu penses bien vous
avez commencé à taper dans un ballon à
l'âge de 4 ans est relativement jeune et
après les faits championnat de france
universitaire de rugby 3e ligne et
aujourd'hui vous aimez toujours bien le
rugby parce que vous regardez les matchs
de rugby à la télé et le foot vous
regardez les résumés mais c'est vrai que
c'est peut-être peut-être trop de foot à
la télé donc c'est plus facile de
regarder les résumés ouais mais j'ai une
passion c'est le rugby et c'est vrai que
ça fait énormément plaisir de les voir
jouer tout le week-end alors en 94 jouer
à mu reste à connaître toulouse c'est ça
voilà vous êtes le maire de toulouse de
murray numéro vous êtes de muret ah bon
parcours
muret coupe de france vous êtes
finalement échoué contre monaco 1-0 et
vous ai fait un bon match et klinsmann
qui avait marqué le but c'est ça la met
à saigner et donc le match j'ai joué un
match assez bon d'ailleurs vous avez
contre vous djorkaeff thuram petit
ettori et donc là vous commencez à être
un peu draguer par les par les clubs les
autres clubs dont nantes
et quand vous arrivez à nantes vous êtes
champion de france
la première année là est d'après demi
finale ligue des champions il vous est
suspendu à ce moment là pour blessure il
ya un type qui prend votre place
s'appelle mickaël landreau qui prend
votre place et là ça commence ay là il a
fini la saison quoi mais tout à fait
normal parce qu'il a précieux qu'il a
pris ma place mais j'étais suspendu puis
blessé
elle a bien réussi l'équipe tournait
bien et ne permet plus donc c'est pas
une petite durée c'est une longue durée
donc c'est tout à fait normal traîne sa
saison puisque ça se passait bien à
laurent soir vous êtes un type de
décision envoie un soir mercredi soir on
vous propose d'aller jouer à seville
vous partez le jeudi et samedi vous
faites votre premier match voilà c'est
vrai sur un coup de tête parce qu'on y
réfléchisse quand même pendant toute la
nuit
ouais mais c'est vrai que c'est une
expérience que j'ai voulu tenter et sans
regret vous êtes passés les formidables
ces villes il ya beaucoup de gens qui
vont au foot là bas qu'on dit 42 mille
personnes pour de la d2 c'est une arme
en face à l'ess il se laisse rêveur que
pour ce à quoi pour le vin
la fête à la limite ouais donc vous
allez donc vous êtes avait été assez
ville et vous êtes recruté par le psg
un lent mais en 98 donc biétry vous
propose de devenir la doublure c'est
comme ça qu'on dit non ses sergents elle
télévisé c'est le joker vous c'est la
doublure de l'ama et il vous donne ça il
vous donne le transfert et 5 millions je
crois donc vous dites vous dites si
mettre ce prix là c'est vraiment je vais
jouer quoi ah non non à cette époque là
tout était clair faire des tris m'a fait
venir me signifiant bien les choses que
je serai remplacé à nevers l'arma et
donc ça c'était la première année et
donc j'étais que prêté par le club
espagnol
c'est la deuxième année où je suis
racheté par le psg l'homme signifie
qu'il y aura une une concurrence avec
dernière la main il ya eu ce qui s'est
passé il va faire bouger dit montrons
enfin vous êtes dit j'ai été trompé quoi
ouais voilà c'est vrai que j'ai pensé
aux mains mais un format menti un peu
comme virenque
vous allez dire m'a menti vous aviez la
haine quand même donc aussi en colère
quand c'est vrai qu'on a la haine parce
que je fais un métier où on a envie de
jouer
ouais j'ai passé un an 1 restait sur le
banc à cirer de bain qui vous ont acheté
pour vous mettre sur le banc de touche
quoi oui voilà
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut toujours de
garder notre club et après quand on
regarde les résultats c'est vrai que ça
donne raison aux dirigeants puisque
bernard lama fait une très bonne saison
être en pétard contre la masse est un
con je ne m'étais jamais un pétard
contre revers de la main autre chose
quand même
non parce qu'on a une bonne discussion
portrait presse interposée au départ
c'est facile de monter toujours là prêt
de monter des petites phrases tout ça et
à son initiative on a eu une bonne
discussion entre cadieux et ça s'est
très très bien terminé et alors là
maintenant c'est réglé quoi en décembre
99 vous avez votre votre contrat et
l'ama est parti en larmes est toujours
là la mapar en fin d'année ouais et
celui qui est sur le banc de touche
maintenant nous devons nous rivalisons
très content lui cracher
[Rires]
il ya vos classiques tirés il va partir
dans un autre club je sais pas encore
qu'est ce qui fait alors la main oui
mais actuellement il joue bas et lui qui
joue elle joue la coupe de la ligue et
en fin de saison mais bernard continuera
sa carrière dans un autre club dans
notre pays on ne sait pas ça ne me
regarde absolument pas et moi je serai à
paris pour débuter après sur les cartes
en main avant d'être bonne
si je suis bon tout va bien je suis pas
juste pas mauvais quand on voit ce que
dira ok j'ai jamais dit ça tu as tenté
d'asseoir enfin je dis ça pour faire un
mot qui est rien dit il a dit qu'il
était très bon ben la voilà
alors bon tout va bien j'aurai mon parc
parole suivi s'occupe bien de toi c'est
fois vous avez la fleur de vue mon avis
on va repartir depardieu
bon ça va la highway savate serge tu
peux me faire la question qui tue la
s'il te plaît
est ce que vous êtes sûr d'être
titulaire l'année prochaine oui
absolument
on est sûr mais de débuter titulaire
c'est le premier match après c'est à moi
de montrer ce que je vaux et et on verra
bien ce jour là mais je suis absolument
sûr d'éviter bon on peut rallumer
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai cru qu'il ya un nouveau goût du
psg qui allait débarquer tu vas tout
d'aller apprendre là en direct et si tu
veux façon et vous allez avoir un second
face au psg bien sûr c'est tout à fait
normal que ça fait comment on sait pas
encore le club cherche ici à le club
cherche
ouais mais c'est tout à fait normal
laisser les chercher alors là on rigole
plus on va passer aux blagues thèse
vient alors le bla une thèse ce soit en
hommage samy naceri et au film taxi 2
qui en est déjà à quatre millions
d'entrées c'est un spécial vroum vroum
première chanson didier attention
d'ivoire
joseph
bravo c'est julie depardieu révélation
serbe
vous êtes là enfin raul que drive my car
les beatles enfin raul bon à lynda lemay
elle et c'est plutôt brel
elle a dit qu'elle voulait être bonnes
soeurs c'est normal qu'ils connaissent
lennon on passe à la suite deuxième
chance qui chante qui chante révélation
du soleil tipi ou non seulement ça fait
un point pour julie depardieu un point
pour dominique qu'à sa grande attention
chanson numéro 3 ça va sauver
on
non
à
[Musique]
parfait pour samy naceri lala jardin
raout et moi là on a l'air de on a l'air
de km à l'est de québec
vous avez l'air de chuck revient à temps
là là c'est pour nous assez pur morceau
numéro 4 monsieur didier sa jeunesse
et
[Musique]
bernard lavigne et non les julie
depardieu
makine des anges j'adore ce moment de
l'émission moi je vous vois chercher
comme ça ça me fait plaisir
toits-jardins bien aller chanson alors
là c'est lui qui arrive là en général on
la reconnaît à la première note parce
que c'est tellement connu c'est
tellement ça si vous vous aussi vous
trouvez battant des sas et si au québec
on connaît ça aussi vous allez voir
numéro 5 didier
[Musique]
là les potes ans
60 ans
suite
lâchés en vidéo
moi c'est très connu 100 0 point cannes
it's a wonderful de ghayne c'est très
très te connaissais passage à ce mythe
un bon le connais pas canned heat
comment voulez que je vous dise caennais
dit on connaît la chanson
si les invités trouve pas le c'est quoi
votre lycée jean monnet tu vois c'est
comme chez drucker ici maintenant et les
lycées qui viennent
j'ai regardé en plusieurs groupes de rap
simple et efficace bien on continue
numéro 6 didier
[Musique]
sur les voitures tartini oui bravo
révélations
t
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quitter trop depardieu elle connaît
anaïs la grande musique quitter
l'autoroute catherine c'est bien et
marque route comme rim pas loin avec
barbelivien derrière c'est julie qui est
en tête je vis je connais quitté le tour
gré c'est bien et ce alors maintenant
alors là ça va revenir via c'est un
chanteur à péage didier
[Applaudissements]
sur lui c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit que
tout à l'heure elle nous en raconter que
des bobards parce que de l'opérationnel
l'a reconnu à l'arrco n'y était pas la
musique classique barbelivien
j'ai une aurait suivi depardieu a
reconnu à cbc et à la première note mais
vraiment la première note alors mais
vraiment la première note là je vous ai
vu bondir ses extraordinaires
enfin c'est un peu plus compliqué ça
parle toujours de bagnols didier s'il
vous plaît pas d'ironie ouais
[Applaudissements]
mauvais coup pour lynda lemay ça si vous
reconnaissez pas votre johnny lors d'un
gp c'est julie depardieu qui a gagné en
l'applaudît bravo
[Applaudissements]
génie
bravo bravo bravo julian rallume rien et
alors raul qui l'a marqué aucun point la
série très très bien sûr cadillac
vraiment alors là bravo c'est un geste
que cello mais vraiment maintenant
l'émission touche à sa fin mais tu last
but not least voici le vrai jeu de la
vraie vérité tout le monde à vous
alors eric raoult holt le principe est
simple
il est 4 heures du matin on est torché
on a fumé quelques pétards et on a
décidé de tout se dire donc vous pouvez
posez vous à tous les gens qui sont sur
ce plateau les questions vous voulez et
bien entendu pareil pour les autres
dominique linda alexandre julie laurent
sami vous pouvez posez vous poser les
questions que vous voulez vous ai pas
osé vous poser pendant l'émission parce
que vous vous toujours un petit peu
évidemment il ya des conventions à la
télévision il a de moins en moins sûr et
vous met un intelligent quelques-unes
alors voilà laurent commencer moi je
dois commencer
oui nous poser à qui vous voulez et sa
peine de me regarder en vendant je vais
demander julie est ce qu'elle a
l'habitude comme ça de rentrer en
contact de façon charnel avec les est ce
que c'est alors eh oui mais je réponds
oui oui une feinte contact corps parce
que sinon je suis perdu voilà elle est
tombée sur vous ont été dégonflés bien
continuer alors avec marie là c'est
chaud là c'est comme c'est comme une
action de cham là il ya des trucs j'ai
senti que c'était possible à bandol
voilà toutes les possibilités possible
comme dizaines de zapper pas cher tout
est possible bien une question à poser à
quelqu'un eric ben moi je voudrais moi
j'en ai pas sûrement dû si c'est pour me
demander du chip jusqu'à lui raul tu vas
tu avais peut-être quoi rouler non voilà
bon posez votre question je voudrais
poser une question à celui qui ment a
posé une c'est que
dans des débats comme ça et c'est grâce
à vous peut-être thierry ardisson dans
cette émission qu'on peut parler
peut-être plus franchement et pas
simplement face à face mais qu'on peut
peut-être être parfois coeur à coeur
c'est de se dire que on comprend mieux
les choses quand on les écoute et moi ce
que j'ai appris en m'occupant de la
banlieue c'est que il ya plein de jeunes
qui voudraient comme joue un jour et
vous êtes un sacré exemple c'est vrai ça
a été un symbole c'est une étape alter a
déconné mais je veux dire ça n'a pas été
facile
moi les portes sont fermées je les ai
j'ai fait en sorte de les combler ouvrés
et les défoncer pour sens propre du
terme
seulement il y en a plein d'autres et
cela il manque d'aidé des petits trucs
enfin le respect de le faire qu'est ce
que les gens du secteur ya des trucs à
faire
il ya des trucs à faire il ya il ya des
millions de jeunes qui sont là qui font
de la musique qui font du sport qui sont
forts et le sud
il vire vire il fume un joint il fume
des joints tu as qui se retrouvent au
cjd a fleuri pompe ils parlent tous mpt
il tourne avec des gangsters et puis
quand il sortait il fonde et je sais pas
il ya un truc à faire pas seulement dire
ouais bon ils sont là allez les sons et
tant pis et la banlieue c'est je sais
pas je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya à faire
moi j'ai eu la chance merci mon dieu si
je suis un exemple si les mecs qui se
disent ouais lui a réussi pourquoi pas
nous et qui se tape comme moi tous les
cas moi je pense sorte de de tendre la
main comme je lé fais jusqu'à
aujourd'hui mais on a besoin de votre
aide
il y en a besoin de vous une question à
quelqu'un je m'en vais pas de questions
linda une question une question jean
n'est plus question
premièrement oui c'est une question
toute simple et très ramassé qu'est ce
que tu penses que ça se peut que c'est
possible des mets ta femme pour toute la
vie sans la tromper sur wii
[Applaudissements]
elle a chance infime simone c'est bien à
toi aussi
weeds en malaisie est ce que tf1 sont
vraies sept mois ouais bah oui ou non je
dirais oui je te croise ces deux là nous
restons là dessus merci aux pour allumer
lumière
bien c'était un slip les unit vous est
fait pour vous en ton nom
c'était tout le monde en parle
loïc et je ne vais pas me gêner son
livre chez plon plus europe + canal du 2
au 14 mai au théâtre de paris avant le
15 et 16 avril au casino du val-andré le
28 avril à lille le 24 avril à digne les
bains
samy naceri la maman pays d'alice
embarque à vie
avec antoine de caunes sortie le 12
avril julie depardieu in extremis
détiennent fort avec sébastien roch
sortie le 19 avril alexandre jardin le
prof
sortie le 12 avril avec jean hugues
anglade yvan attal hélène de fougerolles
et autobiographique de l'amour chez
gallimard
lynda lemay live et le 10 avril à
l'olympia qu elle a battu pouvoir voilà
j'étais tout le monde en parle
rendez vous la semaine prochaine et raul
merci
la grande le 22 avril contre cogniaux
bas arrête cette musique didier arrête
cette musique on mais celle là
oh
[Musique]
non
mon dos
[Musique]
no
m
non
là
jamais non
[Musique]
non
tél
oh
mais
[Musique]